hello everyone welcome to the april 2022
ask me anything edition of the windscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll a
couple days late again uh sorry about
that once again this time my excuse was
for the past three weeks i've been in
santa fe visiting the santa fe institute
as i usually do in my role as what is
called a fractal faculty member i'm
supposed to go there several weeks a
year and uh it's like a part-time
position basically it's the equivalent
of summer salary for those academics out
there
i get my little part-time change of pace
for my regular job by going to sfi and
of course it's amazing fun to be at sfi
but i tried not to do any podcasts while
i was there because well for one thing
i'm supposed to be there doing sfi type
stuff and for another i'm not at home in
my office where i can control the audio
quality so i did one podcast interview
turns out that the the loft that i was
staying in while i was there was quite
echoey so i went into the office to do
the podcast interview i think it did
okay i'm not gonna tell you which one it
was upcoming so if you can't tell then i
win if you can tell so be it sometimes
we deal with what we're stuck with but
like i said sfi is an amazing place it's
unique right it's a research institute
in a very beautiful location in santa fe
not the easiest to get to i wish it were
easier to get there but you can get
there and devoted to the sciences of
complexity in all of their forms you
know the original founders were a lot of
physicists murray gelman phil anderson
uh george cohen and people who are at
los alamos but it's expanded by quite a
bit intellectually into economics and
anthropology and mathematics and a whole
bunch of different things so i don't
know anywhere else in the world i think
this is literally true anywhere else in
the world where you can just randomly
walk into an interesting person walking
down the hallway or even sitting in your
office and interesting people will come
and knock on your door and start asking
you questions whether it's the
foundations of mathematics or the growth
of languages or how to use physics
models in uh understanding politics or
society
it's a great place and in fact there
were several mindscape guests who were
there while i was there jeffrey west of
course
early guest was the former president of
sfi melanie mitchell who's a more recent
guest is one of the most recent hires as
a permanent member of sfi emily riehl a
mathematician was there giving a talk
while i was there and this is the kind
of cool people who just pass through uh
and partly i'm saying this because
people have asked uh if you haven't
heard already i'm going to become a
professor at johns hopkins starting july
1 homewood professor of natural
philosophy is my official title i've
already had people on twitter say in all
seriousness oh we don't have to listen
to him anymore he's declared himself as
a philosopher so this does not bother me
i didn't want you to listen to me anyway
if that's your attitude toward
philosophy but people were asking am i
still going to keep on with the santa fe
affiliation the answer is yes very much
it's very part-time visiting there a
couple times a year completely
compatible with what i'm doing at johns
hopkins so uh
also the last time i was in santa fe it
was last summer there was still a
pandemic we had the vaccine right um but
i mean obviously they're still pandemic
now but there were still mask mandates
and the the suggestion was you should
work from home for very good reasons so
technically i was there
but it was not a lot of interacting
going on whereas this time we had
in-person talks in-person lunches
lunches at sfi are just some of the most
fun events in the world so that was a
lot of fun that's my excuse for being
late with that let's go
[Music]
kathy seeger asks in your blog you wrote
that you'll teach a class about the
physics of democracy could you tell us
what that's about uh yeah that's going
to be one of the first classes i'm
teaching at hopkins in the fall in
september so some of you know because i
think i mentioned it on the podcast at
some point that i'm writing a book
supposed to be writing a book on the
physics of democracy i still am that
book is going to appear at some point
but it's been put on the back burner
while i do other things like the biggest
ideas books
so i thought that it would be a good way
to sort of keep my interest and focus on
the topic while i'm technically writing
other books by teaching a class and in
particular
this class is one of the new first-year
seminars at hopkins you know johns
hopkins is a broad-based research
university has all sorts of departments
and everything but student-wise it is
dominated by students in science
engineering pre-med things like that so
as a result a lot of students have been
starting their college careers at
hopkins by taking nothing but large
lecture classes you know the intro
classes in these science and engineering
and math fields are often just large or
listening to the professor very unlike
the ideal
dream that you have of sitting around a
table with a handful of people
discussing the great ideas of the
universe so recognizing this and
recognizing that undergraduates had been
kind of complaining a little bit that
their introductory experience in the
university uh could be considered a
little bit alienating
hopkins has instituted these first-year
seminars which are mandatory every
student has to take one of these
seminars when they first arrive
and the seminars are on basically
anything they're pass fail it's supposed
to be very
low stress kind of thing but the idea is
that you really dig into a topic
with a professor and with your other
students right i think enrollment's
capped at 12 or 15 or something like
that so you get to know everybody you're
talking about things it's a seminar it's
not a lecture lots of discussion much
more like the ideal college experience
than you might get
so the physics of democracy will be a
physics course technically speaking one
of the funny things was
my physics colleagues at hopkins
apparently were not enthusiastic about
teaching the first year seminars because
they already have their favorite courses
that they like to teach with equations
and lectures and all that uh so i was
very happy to say okay sure i can do
that for my first physics course at
hopkins now as to what it is you know uh
in some sense it's just about learning
about democracy and politics and society
by being inspired by physics examples as
i hinted in the intro there's literally
a talk on this topic at sfi while i was
there and i'm not trying to say that
it's all physics right i'm not trying to
say that you're going to reduce the
behavior of people in societies to the
standard model of particle physics or
anything like that but i do think that
the techniques and way of thinking ways
of thinking about things that physicists
get can be useful ideas about
information flow
phase transitions you know states of of
matter segregation renormalization
there's a lot of ideas that physicists
have that can be productively applied to
society in general and democracy in
particular democracy in particular
because democracy is a quintessentially
emergent phenomenon it is not directed
from top down
there are a lot of agents called
citizens
and they vote and they sort of
collectivize their decision making in
one way or another that's an interesting
question what is the best way to do that
and then you can ask about the features
the dynamics of that decision making and
it's very related to
models in physics where you have little
tiny things that interact with each
other in ways that lead to interesting
emergent behaviors in fact when i
mentioned this to david krakauer the
current president of sfi he said oh yes
all you need to do is study everything
the santa fe institute has ever produced
because that's what it is i mean when
you say complex systems what you're
trying to understand is the simple
emergent behavior in those complex
systems you know the limits of how well
we can understand things what you can
say what you can't and so forth ideally
in a way that is universal among
different kinds of complex systems but
at the very least you can start by
drawing connections between one kind and
another so uh this is just helping me
write a book while also chit-chatting
with the students learning about how
things are going the other course i'll
be teaching will be an upper-level
philosophy course on topics in
philosophy of physics where i'll cover
things like the arrow of time and
quantum mechanics and cosmology from a
philosophical point of view so that
should also be a lot of fun
carlos nunez says what is your opinion
about how the west has dealt with russia
in recent weeks particularly with
regards to the trade-off between
stopping a tyrant versus inciting a
nuclear war
you know uh
i want to say pretty well you know as i
mentioned on twitter
international cooperation is generally
suffers from being slow right you know
there's a conservativeness a
bureaucratic inertia that settles in um
i think that the invasion of the ukraine
has to a remarkable extent united
western democracies against this
particular kind of thing it's almost
without exception
that uh nato and nato adjacent kind of
allies have said no this is not good
what can we do to stop it but as you
hint carlos
there's only so much you can do to stop
it when the other country has nuclear
weapons you know to be brutally honest
and i hate to say this if
you knew for a fact
that the only two choices were
letting russia conquer ukraine or having
a full-scale nuclear war between the u.s
and russia that would leave hundreds of
millions of people dead i think that you
would have to say that letting russia
conquer ukraine is the better option
there i hope that those are not the only
two options and that's that's the trick
right that's the art that is the
difficulty or the interestingness of
being a diplomat in these cases where
you want to try to avoid those two
draconian options so you want to get to
a point where russia has not conquered
ukraine without inciting a nuclear war
now partly
as out of your hands right you can try
but partly if one side starts a nuclear
war then a nuclear war has been started
right
and
what can you do about that so what
you're really trying to do is just lower
the temperature lower the percentage
chance that something terrible like that
is going to happen while still trying to
achieve your goals
so what they're doing is you know uh
diplomatic support economic sanctions
sending some military equipment but
there's a line that they don't want to
cross if if
equipment is sent that's considered okay
that's just considered you know how
things are done but if actual troops are
sent or even people operating the
equipment sent from one country to
another then that other country now
counts as a combatant in the war and
nato countries do not want to be
officially combatants in the war now
it's weird you know just saying it out
loud
these are all rules that people made up
you know and number one did they make up
the right rules number two
are we sure people are going to follow
the rules even if they're the right ones
these are very murky questions so you
have to again you have to balance
kind of expectations from the history of
diplomacy and uh
combat and so forth versus the
possibility someone's just going to do
something completely outside the box so
you know i don't agree with absolutely
everything they've done but i think that
you know so far so good we have not
given up ukraine so far as i'm as i'm
taping this in fact as i'm taping this
the most recent news is that ukraine has
begun to win back some territory which
is kind of amazing i'm a little bit
surprised that they were even able to do
that
but they are and no nuclear war yet so
that's good fingers crossed on that one
luke gendrot says as a non-physicist i
find myself enamored with the concept of
eternal inflation multiversal
cosmologies
intuitively in an infinitely expanding
series of bubble universes feels like as
good a cosmology as any to get behind
i realize feeling like it's a beautiful
cosmology is not a sound basis upon
which to base a scientific theory
however and i'd like to know if you
could expound on what testable
hypotheses are being explored in this
area or have been proposed i also know
physicists tend to be wary about
infinity so i'd be curious to know what
your thoughts are on the topic in
general
yeah well
i'm not sure what to say about your your
statement that feeling like it's a
beautiful cosmology is not a sound basis
on which to base a scientific theory it
certainly shouldn't be your only basis
science has to be fundamentally
empirical right looking at data updating
your priors
as a good bayesian right but on the
other hand
you have priors
that's how bayesian analysis starts and
for me it's just perfectly obvious we're
going to have bigger priors on prettier
more elegant simple scientific theories
than ugly completely ad hoc ones right i
mean why in the world would you not do
that so i think that you know it's a
perfectly legitimate starting point to
say yeah i'm going to start with this
particular idea because i think it's
beautiful but then you have to compare
it to the data you don't stop there
that's the scientific attitude uh now
the idea of eternal inflating universes
etc has been around for a while you know
inflation itself sort of became
officially invented there were precursor
ideas but the official invention was
about 1980
and it wasn't that many years after you
know by the mid 80s we knew that
inflation could lead to an infinite
number of universes
it wasn't until the late 90s so long
after that actually became a super
popular idea for two reasons number one
we developed theories of string theory
that predicted that not only would you
have an infinite number of universes but
the local laws of physics in these
universes could be different now again
this is something that people had i you
know thought about before okay they'd
hypothesized but now you had a
prediction now you had a scheme in which
that was supposed to happen
and number two of course we discovered
the cosmological constant and there was
a pre-existing prediction for the
cosmological constant from stephen
weinberg and others that said if
you have a different number of
cosmological constants in different
parts of the universe and we're only
selected anthropically that is to say we
live in a world where the cosmos
constant lets us live but there's no
dynamical mechanism that is picking its
value then you expect a certain
magnitude and that magnitude is roughly
order of magnitude what was actually
observed okay
so that's both of those give a little
boost to the idea however let's be very
very honest number one none of these
ideas are fully baked none of them is a
rigorously defined theory there's a set
of rules they're kind of ad hoc you do
your best to calculate things under
certain assumptions but you don't know
right i mean these are not as you imply
well-tested ideas so it could be
completely wrong um and the second thing
is there are problems with it it's not
just you know oh wouldn't that be great
it's that you make predictions that you
don't know what to do with people are
not very sure
what the predictions are even for things
like the cosmological constant so what
you're asking is you know
what are the testable hypotheses etc
people propose lots of things but
honestly i wouldn't trust any of them i
think it's very very important to do the
work
but i wouldn't want to be premature
about claiming victory on the basis of
the work being done if that makes sense
so uh you know people are making plots
about what is the mass of the dark
matter or the higgs boson supposed to be
in this kind of collective multiverse
and you know good for them i think it's
worth doing but i wouldn't think that
they're finally there so i'm not going
to give you explicit answer luke i'm
just going to say this is something that
people are working on hopefully we'll
get there at some point craig stevens
says
newton's formulation of gravity relates
the strength of the attraction between
two objects to the mass of each object
and their distance from each other
einstein's formulation is based on the
idea that the mass of an object warps
space-time it seems to me that under
newton's conception light would not be
affected by gravity because it has no
mass but in reality it is affected is it
possible to derive newton's formula for
gravity from einsteins but making some
simplifying assumptions or are they
completely separate formulas that both
happen to work within different realms
so the short answer to this is you can
absolutely derive newtonian gravity from
general relativity from einstein gravity
this is a standard exercise
that is done in any
uh general relativity textbook including
mine taking the newtonian limit so you
consider a bunch of particles well i
guess the the important non-trivial
technical fact is this
there are two limits the limits come in
a sequence there's one limit which is
called the weak field limit okay and in
the weak field limit you just say all
the gravitational pull is relatively
weak in general relativity terms what
you're saying is that
space time is curved but only a little
bit it's pretty much flat okay so that's
a limiting case of general relativity
and it includes the solar system all the
gravitational fields in the solar system
are weak what do you mean by week in
this case there's a numerical criterion
you can think of it as how close are you
to making a black hole okay
nothing in the solar system even if you
think that you know jupiter or the sun
or whatever has a lot of gravity they
are nowhere close to being a black hole
so as far as gr is concerned general
relativity they are weak field gravity
but it also allows for things like
gravitational waves or the deflection of
light
which are not understood in newtonian
regime at all okay so there's an
additional
limit that you take called the newtonian
limit which says that both the
gravitational field is weak and all of
the particles all the objects in your
theory are moving much slower than the
speed of light okay
so this is um
part of just being
newtonian rather than being relativistic
okay
in newtonian mechanics you don't have
any limit on the speed at which things
can move but in relativity you do the
speed of light and so the two theories
overlap
when all the velocities are very very
low compared to the speed of light and
they begin to diverge when the
velocities become close to the speed of
light so therefore if you have a
relativistic theory like gr and you say
but i'm only going to consider
situations where the particles are
moving slowly compared to the speed of
light you can recover the newtonian
predictions
now if you notice
we did not quite in that series of
things i just said weak field limit and
newtonian limit we didn't quite get to a
point where you could compare or think
about deflection of light in the
newtonian limit
because the newtonian limit is particles
are moving slower in the speed of light
and light moves out at the speed of
light
so that's part of the explanation for
why if you're just purely newtonian and
you ask about the deflection of light
it's kind of an unanswerable question
because this idea that there's something
called light the particles of which have
zero mass and they always move at the
speed of light all these notions are
just alien to newtonian physics so if
you i mean light existed before
relativity did or maxwell's equations or
whatever but they didn't know what it
was they didn't know whether it was a
wave or a particle what kind of mass the
particle would have how fast it was
moving anything like that so
nevertheless i think that the spirit of
it is
if you have the particles that are
generating the gravitational field like
the sun and the earth if you have those
be in the newtonian limit
you can ask how is light deflected in a
space-time geometry that is within that
regime and that's where you get the
general relativity formula for the
deflection of light
i do want to make though one philosophy
of science point here so if thomas kuhn
were in the audience the guy who wrote
the structure of scientific revolutions
and uh compared different paradigms in
which people work
he would have emphasized that um
it's not just that you start with
general relativity take some limits and
get back newtonian mechanics or
newtonian gravity because your starting
point is ontologically completely
different okay
meaning that the actual stuff that
you're describing is a completely
different kind of stuff in the two
theories
in general relativity you have space
time it has a metric a curvature and the
curvature responds to energy and
momentum
in newtonian mechanics you have space
and time separately and there's a field
the gravitational field on top of that
that pushes things around so it's a
different language that you're speaking
and so one of the things that kuhn was
skeptical about but i think that you
shouldn't be so skeptical about i think
that we we can do better than kuhn did
is learning how to compare
the understandings that you get within
different paradigms within scientific
pictures and in fact i would say that
general relativity newtonian gravity is
a perfect example of two very different
ontologies two very different sets of
words about what the world is that it's
very straightforward to compare their
empirical predictions and the missing
piece there is that in addition to
general relativity as a scientific
formalism and newtonian gravity as a
scientific formalism we have our
human-based
manifest image of the world right we say
oh i see
stats on my screen of my ccd camera or
you know i see things in the sky etc
okay and we're not comparing these two
theories directly to each other we're
comparing both of them to our
observations so i think
even though kuhn would have said they
are in some sense incommensurable it's
not the perfect example of
incommensurability but it's in the same
spirit i think they're perfectly
commensurable and i think that all
scientific theories more or less are
because you're not comparing one theory
to another you're comparing both of them
to how we experience the world
keith says congratulations on the
homewood professorship at johns hopkins
it seems like a great and exciting fit
best to you and jennifer thank you keith
uh on to the important stuff a huge
congrats to the great seasons of both
the 76ers and the villanova wildcats
what a great overall season for team
sean carroll ariel and caliban better
get max contracts would a villanova
championship be on par with the 76ers
one for you personally or in general if
you feel like sharing thoughts on
differences and your preferences of nba
versus college so here's why i regret
being late because as i'm taping this uh
villanova just lost the uh
it's game in the final four so for those
of you who don't know
number one i was an undergraduate at
villanova university uh they won the
national college basketball championship
my freshman year they've won twice since
then uh and right now as we as we speak
it's the final four in college
basketball march madness and even though
they weren't quite expected to villanova
succeeded in making it up to the final
four then they lost one of their best
players in an injury so he wasn't able
to play in the final four game and they
got more or less
run off the floor by the kansas jayhawks
who were a very high-powered team and so
the uh as i'm taping this
what we know is that the actual
championship game is going to be between
the university of north carolina and can
university of kansas two big public
schools so good for them good for public
education in the united states um
the the question that i'm not going to
spend too much time on but the
interesting question is um professional
nba level basketball versus college uh
purportedly amateur basketball i'm i'm
an nba guy i'm a more of a professional
basketball guy for a bunch of reasons
number one it was my first love you know
my first true fandom in sports was when
julius irving joined the philadelphia
76ers in the mid-1970s
and those sixers teams in dr j's day
were endlessly entertaining and of
course they won us a championship in
1983 so my heart was stolen there
i have mixed feelings about college
sports in general you know i will root
for villanova when they're uh playing
and and it's a lot of fun to watch them
you know um there's a lot more people
who get to play high level
college basketball than professional
basketball so it's a important thing in
their lives and i appreciate that um but
yeah college sports is just messed up
for all sorts of reasons
uh most obviously of which the
schools and the coaches and the national
collegiate athletic association make
huge amounts of money off of these
people and the students make nothing
they get uh
the the team players the the athletes
they get free tuition um at the
university but that is dwarfed by the
actual amount of money that the
universities are making so it's a bit of
a scam actually uh and it's a scam that
the professional leagues play along with
because in both college and sorry in
both basketball and football in
particular college basically acts as a
minor league for the professional
leagues
and there are even rules about how you
have to go to college before you can go
to the professional leagues and and that
kind of makes no sense to me i think
that that's just a scheme to get people
rich uh other than the actual athletes
doing the work so i have slightly mixed
feelings about that whereas on
professional basketball everyone gets
paid hands handsomely
and you can argue the the details but
also
with the
current standing the current way that
the college ranks go the very best
players in college basketball only play
for a year before they go to the nba
because that's what the rules let them
do so you don't get to like see them
progress over time in a way that you
would with the professional teams so
there you go on the other hand with the
problem with the professional teams is
that players can get traded right
players do get traded all the time so
in some sense you're trying to root for
this continuous ship of theseus uh in
the form of the team that is constantly
changing its ingredients but somehow it
works somehow you know your emotions get
attached that way perfectly effectively
simon carter says i've just finished
reading the excellent book how to make
an apple pie from scratch by harry cliff
harry mentions svalarons as a potential
solution to the matter antimatter
asymmetry what credence do you give to
this being correct and if not svalurons
what do you think most likely caused the
universe to be dominated by matter and
not anti-matter so for those of you who
are not familiar with the idea of
spallerons uh you know not many people
are in fact most people who get phds are
probably never exposed to phds in
physics i probably never expose the idea
of a celeron it's something that happens
late in your education in quantum field
theory in the standard model of particle
physics
uh if that is your specialty and it's
not most people's specialty but it's not
that hard to understand the implications
of it even if the details are kind of
mathematical a speluron sounds like a
particle right like a proton neutron
sphaleron but it's not it's a process
really it's a dynamical thing that can
happen in the electroweak part of the
standard model of particle physics the
uh the part of the standard model that
unifies the weak interactions with the
electromagnetic interactions via the
higgs boson right that famous thing that
i wrote a book about
and the sphalleron is one of these very
fun intellectually fun exercises where
you can change the topology of the
fields
dynamically in some quantum fluctuation
and in the process of doing that you
change the number of particles and when
you change the number of particles you
don't have to
change it equally in the particle versus
antiparticle sectors okay you can change
the total number of what we call baryons
strongly interacting particles like the
proton and the neutron are uh baryons so
you can change baryons into antibarions
leptons into antileptons etc that's
important and interesting because as you
probably know there is an imbalance in
the observed world between the number of
matter particles and the number of
antimatter particles and there's an
ongoing mystery in cosmology why is that
you maybe imagine that it was just baked
into the initial conditions of the
universe but for various reasons
physicists prefer to imagine that it was
dynamically generated that the universe
started with an equal number
maybe zero who knows of particles and
antiparticles and there was an imbalance
created in matter versus antimatter
along the way so if sphalerons can do
this maybe they are responsible now
we've never seen this valaron okay these
transitions are supposed to be very rare
we've never seen one in the lab but
they're theoretically on quite a sound
basis
they're also not enough to get you a
real physical imbalance between
particles and antiparticles because
sphalerons as a class of possible things
they don't care whether it's
positive uh mass part or not positive
mass whether it's
positive baryon number particles or
negative baryon number particles okay
they don't really care whether they're
making protons or antiprotons so you
need to somehow tilt the balance there
and it was andre sacharov the famous
russian physicist who really laid down
the rules for when this could happen you
departure from thermal equilibrium you
need to violate the difference between
baryon and anti-baryon number but you
also separately need to violate you know
charge parity symmetry or okay all of
these symmetries are very easily
violated in the standard model particle
physics but the rates are just so tiny
that they don't explain what we actually
see so that's why there's a whole field
bariogenesis trying to understand why
there's more baryons than anti-baryons
so the question is do salarons play a
role in that and the answer is maybe
there are many many different versions
of bariogenesis on the market
some of them make useless valorons and
some don't okay
i haven't actually followed the very
most recent research in this area it's
not exactly my area the last time i did
pay attention to it the most plausible
sounding mechanism to me
was some kind of something that involves
neutrinos at super high energies you
know super high energies you can make
these neutrinos that themselves in their
decays they can be very massive
neutrinos and they can decay
preferentially into either baryons or
antibaryons so this is called
leptogenesis
neutrinos are leptons not baryons but
then you can convert the leptons into
baryons in some way so there are many
elaborate schemes to do this i'm
certainly not an expert so don't ask me
but um
it's it's an interesting question
because the fact
that there are more baryons and
anti-baryons is very empirically true
right like we didn't make that up so
it's a very down-to-earth fact
the theories that we have to explain it
seem to be just a bit outside what we're
able to test in the lab so it's hard to
know how to make progress in the short
term but again just like with uh the
anthropic principle or something like
that you got to keep trying got to keep
pushing on that and try to make better
predictions and hopefully we will figure
it out at some point
tyler ogarak says what was the
inspiration behind the names ariel and
caliban ariel and caliban are two
characters in shakespeare's play the
tempest which is a favorite of both
jennifer and myself and also
when we got them you know they so we got
them
these are our two kittens by the way or
two cats by now they're five years old
uh for those of you who are just tuning
in for the first time i have two cats
ariel and caliban
um we got them from a shelter santa door
rescue uh here in los angeles i
encourage you to support or get your
cats from if you're interested and
when the kittens are in the shelter
they're just given names they're like
mass-produced names right so they have
algorithms so we were going through a
star wars phase in the naming of
kittens at santa dora at the time and so
let me see if i can get them right i
think they were gin and cassian right i
think that those are from rogue one but
i'm not sure i'm
revealing my lack of complete star wars
knowledge right now uh so
we had to figure out if we were going to
keep them what the names would be we're
allowed to change the names etc and
honestly to both of us they both kind of
reminded us of the actual characters
ariel and caliban you know in the play
ariel is
kind of angelic almost they're both
they're both
quasi-supernatural
spirits of some sort and ariel is very
light they're both boys in the play but
uh our ariel is a girl um but anyway
ariel is very like you know pristine and
pretty and and and uh perfect and
glowing
and our little kitten ariel is you know
perfectly formed very sharp features
uh very elegant and a little bit high
strung whereas caliban in the play is
more like rough and nature like and you
know beastly and as much as we love him
our little boy caliban when he was young
he's he's not you know he's handsome but
he's not classically handsome if you
know what i mean he's a little bit
asymmetrical uh his teeth his fangs are
a little bit too long his fur is a
little bit too long he looks all goofy
honestly so he kind of looked like a
caliban that was basically the answer
and their personalities worked out to be
fitting to those two names so it all
came out pretty well
robert ruxin rescue says i have a
question about space-time versus quantum
fields can you have quantum fields
without space time can you have any kind
of space time without any quantum field
in it at all
so it depends on what you mean by can
in other words in the real world
we have space time and quantum fields in
it at least at the level of description
where space time exists and stuff like
that let's assume that that's the level
of description at which we are working
all space time has quantum fields in it
because the ingredients of the universe
are points in space time and a set of
fields defined at each one of those
points the same set of fields right so
within our observable universe anyway
it's the same
collection of possible quantum fields
the electron field the photon field etc
at every point having a value at every
point so can you have quantum fields
without space time no because the
definition of a field
is something that is a function of space
time that's what it is okay not rather
rather than something that is just a
function of a point or something like
that can you have space-time without any
quantum field in it at all not in our
universe not in our observable universe
that we know and love you can imagine
space-time without quantum fields in it
but even that is hard you get to stretch
the definition a little bit
because always on space time you have a
metric right
you have the thing that determines the
geometry of space-time that what
einstein allows to be curved even if you
didn't allow it to be curved there would
still be a metric but you could sort of
imagine
a world
that was newtonian
in spirit or even let's say special
relativistic in spirit okay
so there's a fixed space time so you
have a metric but it's not fluctuating
and therefore there's not really a
quantum version of it it's just a fixed
fact about the universe
and then you could just
think about you know particle mechanics
in that universe that's what newton
thought about right or even that's what
niels bohr would have thought about
before quantum field theory came along
quantum particle mechanics so you can
imagine hypothetical worlds in which
space-time exists but quantum fields
don't but that's not our world in which
we actually live
nick c says people sometimes claim that
it is improbable that the physical
constants of the universe admit the
possibility of anything resembling what
we think of as life this comes into
various other arguments about
intelligent design etc
but i always get stuck at this first
point i've never been able to see how
that claim can be rigorously made i
don't understand how we would know what
the range of possible values for each of
these constants is or what probability
distribution to assign them it seems
like a thought it seems like thoughtful
people give this idea credence so what
am i missing yeah i'm a little bit
sympathetic to your worries nick but i
think that there's a judicious middle
position here um you're absolutely right
that people do make the claim
that if you think of all the constants
of the physical universe you know the
masses of the particles the fine
structure constant the gravitational
constant what have you
um
the claim that is made is that if i
generically chose
points in the space of all possible
values for those constants most of those
points would not lead to universes that
allowed for the existence of life
clearly
that claim
only makes sense if you know what you
mean when you say if you generically
choose some set of values
rigorously speaking what that means is
you need to measure on the space of all
these constants and generally people
have a measure in the back of their mind
namely it's a uniform measure it's
uniformly likely let's say that you know
the fine structure constant which
empirically is about 101 over 137
you could say well maybe it's a random
number chosen between zero and one
and someone else can say well
why zero and one i got minus one in a
billion or plus a billion and plus two
billion like why did you choose that and
the answer is nobody has any principal
reason for choosing that uh
so there really isn't
any uh very rigorous statement that you
can make along these lines
okay but on the other hand
um there seems to be something real
going on here you know in the case of
the cosmological constant the vacuum
energy
we don't know for sure what is the right
measure to use or even if it's sensible
to say that there is a measure i mean
after all if there's only one universe
which maybe there is and it just has a
value
of the vacuum energy or the fine
structure constant or whatever what does
it mean to say that it's
chosen randomly at from some
distribution it's not it's just a value
it's just one thing okay but okay let's
put that aside for the moment um given
physics as we currently understand it
there isn't a measure on the space of
possible values of the of the vacuum
energy
and there's also no reason why it
shouldn't be at the plank scale
or minus the planck scale so it should
be it could be any number as far as we
currently know between the planck scale
and minus the planck scale and the point
of the fine-tuning argument is that in
order for life to exist
it had to turn out
that the values of the cosmological
constant were less than something like
10 to the minus 120
uh times the planck scale okay in in
magnitude so between minus 10 minus 120
and plus 10 minus 120. and the idea is
which i i think it makes sense to me the
idea is that in the absence of any
particular
rigorously defined measure on the space
of possibilities
that still seems like a really narrow
window
and in fact people like steven weinberg
have tried to make this rigorous by
saying look in the space of all smooth
functions that you could imagine on the
values of the cosmos constant
exactly because you're zooming in on
such a tiny region
that that smooth function will probably
look flat probably look uniform because
most most functions look flat in very
very tiny regions of space right
now that's a bad argument by itself
because
the particular regime we're looking at
for the cosmological constant includes
the value zero which might be special
there might be that there is a measure
on the value of cosmological constants
that is singular that is infinitely big
at zero or something like that uh but we
just don't know so i think that you're
right to think that again it's not
finished i should i could have grouped
this with the earlier question i think
that there is something there some
intuition that is being pumped
uh by this idea that they find that the
constants of nature seem finely tuned
but it is not a rigorous argument
so the question is what do you do about
that what do you do when you don't have
a rigorous argument but you have some
intuition so one attitude to take is
yeah i don't trust that argument at all
right unless it's rigorous i'm not going
to believe it
that's okay you're allowed to have that
attitude but the problem is you're not
going to get very far in real world
physics because you'll soon discover
that many many things that we
are very successful at using are not on
a rigorous foundation so that's kind of
a problem the other you know extremist
attitude just to say you know it's good
enough i think the argument works
therefore the anthropic principle must
be the answer to something like this um
i don't think that's right either i
think that you should sort of
keep in mind that these arguments seem
to make sense but they are not rigorous
therefore we should try to do better at
them i think it is wrong either to
dismiss them entirely or to take them
too credulously that's my personal
attitude
okay
i'm gonna
group two questions together about
aliens stuart haynes says in the intro
to your recent podcast with eric
kirschenbaum you stated that you thought
it's unlikely that in our galaxy there
are other very advanced technological
civilizations if there were it would be
very easy to have noticed them already
and we haven't
what means do we now have to detect
civilizations on exoplanets that are not
producing results is it chemical
signatures and atmospheres or some other
means
i think you may have said that the most
likely means for a distinct distant
civilization to make contact would be
through von neumann machines perhaps
parking them at lagrange points around
foreign planets
and brad malt says in your aliens
podcast this month you muse about why we
haven't noticed any extraterrestrial
technologically advanced civilizations
could your looming disasters podcast
provide part of the answer
you know here so the the big question
here is the fermi paradox right why
haven't we detected technologically
advanced aliens yet and i think one of
the reasons why this paradox is so hard
or so puzzling is because it's easy to
come up with reasons such as in the
looming disasters podcast why any
individual technological civilization
might destroy itself it's not that hard
to imagine that possibility but if you
really thought
that technological civilizations were
thick on the ground as it were
then you only need one of the ones in
the past in our past light cone to
escape killing themselves and that
civilization could fill the galaxy the
important number here is that the
universe is 14 billion years old let's
give it a couple billion years to to
make stars and things like that but you
know you can imagine that stars in our
galaxy are
certainly billions of years old okay um
i mean our sun is
over over 4 billion years old so maybe
10 billion years worth of star formation
and and uh
intelligent civilization building
but the speed of light crosses the
galaxy in 100 thousand years that's
nothing you can cross the galaxy back
and forth a lot and if even if you say
you know well i don't think they could
go the speed of light all right let them
go at one percent at the speed of light
then you can cross back and forth the
galaxy in 10 million years one way or
another it's a lot less
than 10 billion years that it took uh
that we've been making stars so we have
a really rich past of possible
extraterrestrial civilizations coming
into existence in our past light cone
and you have to believe that none of
them
have or it is true let's say that none
of them have contacted us okay that is i
know that other people disagree about
that but that's my attitude towards
other civilizations contacting us so far
if the contact were going on via radio
signals or whatever then it's very easy
to understand why they would not contact
us yet because
you can easily if you're an advanced
civilization you can easily send out
radio signals that we could detect but
why in the world would you keep doing
that for 10 billion years that seems
like a waste of resources right
whereas if you just build a spacecraft
and send those spacecrafts to other
parts of the galaxy and sit and wait for
the emergence of life
then you can do it very easily right
again just move it one percent the speed
of light in 10 million years you've
filled the whole galaxy and the
reference that stewart is making to fund
neumann machines is that jon von neumann
figured out a way to make a machine that
can build replications because they can
replicate itself okay so send out one
it's kind of like a nasty virus you send
out one little funeral machine it goes
to another solar system gets the raw
materials creates 10 copies of itself
they all go to other star systems etc
and they park and they wait now maybe
you think well okay i don't think that
the civilization would want to do that
again the pro the problem is you have to
think that no civilization would have
ever wanted to do that and it's
absolutely possible that no civilization
would have wanted to do that but at this
point
to me it just becomes easier to imagine
there aren't any such civilizations okay
certainly that's up that seems more
plausible to me than uh they're there
but they're not talking to us they're
waiting for us to grow up again all you
need is one dissenter from that
consensus um or or something like that
you know and again this is not something
i have very high credence and i'd be
very happy to be wrong we should still
keep looking blah blah blah but
to me the simplest explanation for why
none of this has happened is that there
are no technologically advanced
civilizations out there probably because
you know the various
stumbling blocks or bottlenecks i should
say in the development of complex life
are hard to overcome you know here on
earth it was easy to make life it was
hard to make eukaryotic life it was hard
to make multicellular life etc so
i think it's just very plausible there's
life out there in the universe and none
of that none of it uh nearby has any
advanced technology i guess we'll see
kyle stevens says what makes for a good
interviewee without needing to name
names has anyone struck stuck out as a
particularly good or bad at handling an
interview and if so why
well yeah i mean there's certainly
things about interviewee uh that make
them good or bad it's a skill okay it's
not really surprising and this comes up
with me personally because i want to as
i've said you get a lot of different
kinds of people
on the podcast and one dimension
that is relevant is seniority right
there are some people you have on the
podcast this is not their first rodeo
they've been on podcasts they've been
giving public talks they are senior
people not only the skill of
speaking and being interesting and so
forth but also the skill of
having an understanding of what part of
your subject matter is really
interesting and being able to share it
quickly okay having not necessarily uh
sound bites but at least an ability to
dive to the important part of what
you're talking about and get rid of the
less interesting parts maybe you can
make it charming with some stories and
stuff like that that would be the ideal
kind of um
podcast guest and you know i remember
very explicitly when i was sometime
during my postdoctoral years and i began
to occasionally get called
by journalists you know writing stories
about cosmology or particle physics or
whatever and
part of your first response is yes but i
didn't write that paper so i shouldn't
talk about it you know you're asking me
to talk about somebody else's paper
but you know it is part of the job
as an academic as a professor etc to be
a spokesperson for your field right to
be able to talk about it so you have
your specific research agenda and the
research you do
but you also
you don't it's not an absolute necessity
but it's good and nice and
virtuous
if you have enough knowledge about the
broader aspects of the field that you
can intelligently talk about it and put
things into context
communicating with the broader public is
part of the portfolio of the field
anyway if not of each individual person
so
a lot of the young people so i like to
get young people and older people i like
to get people you've never heard of and
people you certainly have heard of uh
and you know the young people have not
had enough time to develop these skills
so some of them are just natural
geniuses at it that's great others you
know will be really good at it 20 years
from now but haven't figured that out
yet uh so that's one dimension on which
i'm still gonna do it i'm still gonna
invite young people on if i think they
have really interesting ideas because
you know that's how they're gonna learn
right by uh being on these podcasts and
you will learn about things that you
might otherwise not hear about from the
older people there's a there's a
perspective that youth and energy and
vigor bring
that is not going to be there in the
older people so i think that's still
very very important um you know
otherwise you know yeah there's a wide
range of ways to be good at being a
podcast uh guest some are basically
giving their talk
except it's on a podcast others are you
know very happy to ramble off on
tangents whatever those tangents may be
you know the perfect podcast guest is
one who
answers the questions but also
understands that they are the expert not
me right so they know better than i do
what they should be talking about so i
will ask a question and they will be
able to say you know here's the answer
to your question and also maybe the
question you should have asked was this
other one okay i like that that's what
i'm looking for in a good podcast guest
there's also you know kind of trivial
questions like uh some people just want
to give one sentence answers all the
time other people are not happy unless
they're talking for half an hour
uninterrupted and there is some happy
medium there as well in terms of podcast
guests
you know often i know about people's
stuff from reading right what they've
written their papers their books or
whatever and i just don't know that much
about their speaking style so there's
always going to be some hit or miss and
you know i i don't mind that i would
like more hits than misses but the
excitement the unpredictability that's
all part of the fun
jesse rimler says
do you have a recommendation for someone
who's interested in getting into math
for fun as an adult
i'm looking into the khan academy and
other resources but i'm not quite sure
what course of study is appropriate do
you think someone who did not do well in
school and has barely used math in
decades should restart at pre-algebra
say rather than dive into a more
interesting and advanced subject so i
actually am not good at giving
recommendations you know specific
operational recommendations about khan
academy or some other resources i have a
vague feeling there are a lot of
resources out there there is khan
academy there's one reum podcast
advertiser gotta you know put in a good
word for them they have a lot of good
courses and lectures on things like that
and there's also just other kind of
moocs right massively online courses
that you can check out uh so but you can
google that as well as i can i do not
know much about the details
the question is more specific about
should you start a pre-algebra rather
than dive into more interesting advanced
subjects you know it depends if what you
want is kind of a
fun interesting diversionary uh tickle
your brain kind of introduction to some
cool ideas in math then you know pick up
a good popular book about math you know
we've had people like jordan ellenberg
steven strogatz on the podcast who have
written
uh very good popular level books on math
uh tai jinay bradley has website that is
also a very good introduction
uh but if you want to really understand
the deeper aspects then you gotta start
at the beginning math is an extremely
cumulative subject i'm a big believer
that it is possible to understand
higher levels of math whether it's you
know calculus or the kind of stuff we
talked about with emily real category
theory very very abstract stuff you can
understand that but you do need the
background and pre-algebra is a good
place as any to start you need the
basics of functions
pushing around functions maybe a bit of
geometry certainly calculus okay and
then you can go from there uh and it's
fun i think it's very worth doing the
resources are out there so i'd encourage
you to at least give it a try see how
far you get
antoine chopin says integrated
information theory iit which was
initially proposed by giulio tinoni in
2004 claims that consciousness is
identical to a certain kind of
information
the realization of which requires
physical not merely functional
integration and which can be measured
mathematically according to the phi
metric does this theory seem appealing
to you you know it's appealing to me but
i don't quite agree with it
and i say that with enormous caution
because i'm not an expert and i've said
this i've opined about iit integrated
information theory before knowing that i
am not an expert so you shouldn't listen
to my opinion about it but my vague
impression is
that maybe
the phi metric on some complex system
that is supposed to be either conscious
or not
gives you a
necessary condition for being conscious
i'm much less persuaded it gives you a
sufficient condition for being conscious
in other words it just seems too easy
to me to imagine systems with high
amounts of phi and yet we would not
recognize them as conscious
and you know maybe look in some sense
that's okay like we did you know when we
talked with stewart bartlett about life
um and he makes the he made a very good
point that
what we call life here on earth has a
number of distinct characteristics that
can in principle be separated out right
some systems will reproduce others will
have metabolisms of a certain kind you
know there's different things that you
might all associate with life and you
can take or leave individual parts of
them i think that consciousness is
probably similar i bet that there's
probably a number of things that one
could try to
make rigorous and explicit
about what is involved in what we think
of as consciousness and maybe phi is
getting one of them
but maybe not the whole thing but you
know i really should learn more about it
honestly it's one of the things on my
list of things to learn more about so
that i shouldn't say anything more than
that
scott says my kids have started asking
me interesting physics questions
recently one asked how potential energy
is converted to kinetic energy in the
context of classical electrodynamics
charged particle and electric field
i said that energy is not a substance
but a really useful accounting trick
that lets you keep track of the position
and motion of the particle in the field
without having to do numerical
integration
in particle physics the energy seems to
be most the most important thing about
any system
and it's right there is h in
schrodinger's equation so what is the
right way to think about energy useful
accounting trick fundamentally important
or both
you know i'm on the useful accounting
tricks side largely i would say here in
fact what you said about energy is not a
substance but you know a parameter a way
of thinking a feature a property of the
physical system you're looking at that's
something i've said myself before and i
don't think that changes any uh from
classical mechanics to quantum mechanics
the usefulness of the concept you know
you you kind of are choosing a
rhetorical strategy when you call it a
useful accounting trick it's a very
useful accounting trick it is a way of
thinking about the world that is very
very powerful right i mean the existence
of the desk in front of me is a useful
accounting trick to talk about a whole
collection of atoms and particles and
things like that right but it's a very
useful accounting trick so much so that
i tend to think of my desk as a real
thing that is sitting in front of me so
in quantum mechanics i mean let's put it
this way
in classical mechanics if you were isaac
newton
when you wrote down newton's equations
for physics you never mentioned the word
energy the idea of kinetic energy was
not one that was in newton's toolbox he
talked a language of forces and
accelerations right you have a position
a velocity acceleration of force those
are the fundamental ingredients for
newton it wasn't until later madame du
chatelet etc that we figured out the
distinction between momentum and energy
and we got the equations for them down
right and then hamilton figured out a
way to do classical mechanics
based on the energy
so the whole idea of hamiltonian
mechanics is just a rewrite of newtonian
mechanics it's not a new physical theory
but it's a new language in which to talk
about newtonian mechanics where the
energy of the system is the primary
thing
so hamiltonian mechanics starts with an
equation for
energy as a function of position and
momentum
and from that one equation it gives you
a recipe for deriving all of the
equations of motion in newtonian
mechanics okay we call that hamiltonian
mechanics even though it's physically
equivalent to
newtonian mechanics by the way i have a
book coming out that will explain all of
this this is all talked about
uh including hamiltonian mechanics and
lagrangian mechanics in the biggest
ideas in the universe coming out in
september
but in quantum mechanics the point is
that we have the schrodinger equation
yes and the schrodinger equation
certainly features the hamiltonian which
is that uh thing invented by hamilton
the way to express the energy of the
system
in terms of its velocities and its
momentum schroedinger turns that into an
operator on wave functions but it's the
same basic idea
so i would say that energy doesn't play
any more important role in quantum
mechanics than it did in classical
mechanics it's just that you're using a
useful accounting trick to write to the
theory in a way that uses energy in a
very straightforward important central
way
so i would say that something can be a
useful accounting trick and
fundamentally important at the same time
and energy
certainly qualifies as well as anything
that i can think of
okay sen deep chitale is asking a
priority question and so i edited this
question a little bit because it was a
priority question but it was long i
meant to say this in the intro but let
me say it now um because now that we're
in the regime where i don't get to
answer every question people want to
know why do i answer some questions
rather than others there's lots of
things that go into it as i've said you
know do i personally have something
interesting to say likewise do i think
that what i have to say will be
interesting to the rest of the world
that's also interesting but a third
criterion is i would like the questions
to be short
i am not in favor of long questions
because it just takes time from
they're both hard to understand audio
visually i mean there's no visual right
so you're just listening to my voice and
reading a question is one thing but
listening to someone say a question out
loud is a different thing so uh keeping
the question short makes it more
comprehensible to the audience and it
also you know is a little bit respectful
of the time that is taking away from
other people's questions anyway i don't
mean to pick on you sandeep i know
you're a long uh time listener i
appreciate it uh but i did edit your
question down that's all i'm saying here
and if other people did not get their
questions answered at all
ask how many paragraphs were in your
question and if the answer is more than
one you might have stumbled across the
reason
so the question is it is said that
microphysics is time reversible to me
what should actually be said is that
microphysics is velocity reversible
to me reverse time is nonsensical what
does that even mean the direction of
time is implicitly defined by the
preceding events followed by succeeding
events
if we agree the time can only flow in
one direction from preceding to
succeeding then by definition it does
not need anything else to explain its
direction then why do we need a low
entropy state of the big bang the past
hypothesis so there's a couple things
going on here
one is
the whole point of the arrow of time
problem is that the setup that you've
proposed where the direction of time is
implicitly defined by preceding events
going to succeeding events
is just not there in fundamental physics
in the equations of motion whether
hamilton's equations which we just
talked about or newton's equations or
the schrodinger equation or whatever
their time is just a label
and there is no directionality to it so
by just a label what i mean is
mathematically
i can invent a new time coordinate and i
can vent it by saying let's let t prime
equal minus t
okay
now the equations
of either hamiltonian mechanics or
newtonian mechanics or whatever in some
sense work equally well
when you do that letting t go to minus t
you can run the movie forward or
backwards the level of fundamental
physics the subtlety there there's a
footnote okay which is what you're
putting your finger on when you say
velocity reversible rather than time
reversible okay because
technically
let's let's think about it in terms of
hamiltonian mechanics because the
interesting thing about hamiltonian
mechanics is
that
you don't define momentum as mass times
velocity you derive that momentum is
mass times velocity but momentum is
starts life as something completely
independent okay there's an equation of
motion that says momentum is mass time
velocity but you don't assume it from
the start
and there indeed
for a typical standard kind of
dynamics for physical systems expressed
in the rules of hamiltonian mechanics
to have this property
that you can
reverse the direction of time as a
matter of
parameter choice you also need to
reverse the direction of momentum that's
what you're sort of getting at when you
say velocity reversible so the rule is
in hamiltonian mechanics i have a
collection of particles they have
positions they have velocities or
momenta i evolve it forward in time
get some new collection of positions and
momenta i reverse all momentum okay so i
create a new state called the time
reversed state which is keeping all the
positions the same but reversing all the
momentum and then i evolved backward in
time and i can do that i can just put
minus t into the equations then i get a
yet another state and i untime reverse
it okay so that that final state i'm
going to remove i'm going to reverse all
of its momentum and the the non-trivial
result is
that process evolve forward in time time
reverse evolve backward in time time
reverse again that gets you back to your
initial state that is the statement of
time reversibility in physics and it's
just as true in the schrodinger equation
except rather than going from
momentum to minus momentum you go from
wave function to complex conjugate of
the wave function there you go okay
now the point is that when you have that
property
when you have reversibility the
reversibility says that the amount of
information contained in the state at
any one point in time is preserved over
time
you can evolve forward or backward
without losing information and that's
true about microphysical dynamics
newtonian or hamiltonian or schrodinger
or whatever it's not true about
macrophysical dynamics if i have a
classic example you know if i uh have a
glass of warm water with an ice cube or
i have a glass of cool water they will
both evolve into a glass of cool water
and seeing that final state
macroscopically doesn't let me
just decide which one came from if i see
a glass of cool water i don't know if it
just was a glass of cool water or
whether it was a glass of warm water
with an ice cube they look the same but
micro physically i would be able to tell
if i knew all the positions and momenta
and that's why you need the past
hypothesis because the whole point
is to connect the microphysical theory
to the macrophysical theory
it is a fact about the world that
entropy
increases over time and we
have very very strong belief that it was
lower in the past but that's not
dynamically necessary you know given the
state of the world now
and the microscopic laws of physics
if that's all you knew when you gave
sort of equal probability to any
microphysical state that was compatible
with our macroscopic knowledge
with overwhelming probability you would
predict that the past used to be high
entropy and no one thinks that's true so
you need a hypothesis that says it is
low entropy at the big bang
now to be fair
the story i'm just telling you here this
is the standard story this is what most
physicists or philosophers would tell
you there are
uh
people who don't go along with a
standard story there are people who like
you say
uh
really think that time just has a
direction
built into it okay that there is a flow
from the past to the future i don't
think that most working physicists don't
think that but there are people who
think that okay
i still think that even if you believe
that it doesn't by itself tell you why
the past had low entropy so the way that
to me the logic goes in the following
way
you might want to think
that time fundamentally has a direction
or the time doesn't fundamentally have a
direction it's just that it started with
low entropy and so we perceive it to
have a direction macroscopically okay
um but
if you think the time fundamentally has
a direction you still need to explain
why the early universe had low entropy
you know that doesn't come for granted
there's no there's no feature about
saying time has a direction that then
says if i take the current state of the
universe and evolve into the past the
entropy goes down there's no connection
there right so even if you believe that
time has a direction
you still need to have some past
hypothesis and once you have the past
hypothesis you don't need to assume that
time has a direction because it will
have a direction macroscopically even if
microscopically it's completely
reversible i think that's why most
people like the past hypothesis package
when it comes to explaining the
asymmetry of time
thomas prunty says congrats on the new
position at johns hopkins you mentioned
they are encouraging you to keep up your
other activities but i think something's
got to give do you foresee a slowdown in
the podcast schedule or trade or
textbook writing um you know i get it
thank you thomas i i get the concern
i've had it myself but i guess we'll
have to see okay i mean i have a lot of
obligations
to both write things um and to teach
courses and things like that i think i
can do it uh but we'll have to see maybe
something we'll have to give i'm not
going to kill myself or you know drive
myself to distraction doing these things
i certainly have no plans right now to
slow down the podcast schedule um uh at
any at any time i did i toyed with the
idea of maybe slowing it down
a fraction
by
instead of doing a brand new interview
episode every monday i just make the
amas count as a new monday episode okay
so that removes one interview i need to
do every month uh but while still giving
you a new podcast once a week um i don't
know whether i'm going to do that or not
right now again that is not the plan but
that is a possible future plan if it
becomes unbearable otherwise
emmett francis says i was recently
excited to receive an email from
biophysical society saying that they
will put out an issue on emergent
phenomena in biophysics but when reading
their email they define emergence as
systems of many components whose
collective behavior is governed by their
interactions so that the whole is
greater than the sum of its parts this
strikes me as more of a definition of
strong emergence which seems
non-physical to me is there any way to
reconcile this definition with physics
or have they just gotten it wrong
well you know certainly one issue in the
study of things like emergence is we
don't agree on the definition okay um
i can give my definition of it and
someone i mean this literally happened
not that long ago someone in the middle
of conversation says that's just not
emergence you know you can't win or lose
an argument about that uh
it's a definition you people can just
have different definitions okay
now
the specific issue with the definition
that you're quoting i wouldn't
necessarily say that the issue is that
it's non-physical because it's strong
emergence i think it's just not very
well defined okay so the whole is
greater than the sum of its parts that's
their definition
what does that mean like what how do i
know that the hole is greater than some
of its parts how do i know what the sum
of these parts is
right um that's why part of what one
should do if one wants to have a
principal discussion about these things
is be a little bit more clear about what
your definitions are do you mean that so
just to back up for those people who are
not experts i should apologize because
i'm sort of embedded in these debates so
i forget sometimes
there's a famous distinction between
strong and weak emergence
probably the clearest version of which
was given by a philosopher named mark
badao in a in a paper i think called
weak emergence
because people have talked for many many
years about the idea of emergence and i
think the part of the idea of immersions
that everyone agrees on
is there's a way of talking about a big
macroscopic system that is a collection
of little parts that doesn't directly
refer to those little parts right when
you talk about the table in front of me
i can talk about the table being solid
or brown or whatever without talking
about its atoms that's a common feature
of emergence the question is weak versus
strong are those features of the table
in principle
coming down to just the collective
behavior of the individual atoms and
particles obeying their individual lower
scale laws of physics
in which case it would be called weak
emergence and what badow very cleverly
did is said look
if you have some lower level laws
governing the atoms or whatever and in
principle i could do a numerical
simulation i could put those laws of
physics on a computer and i could ask
what happens and the prediction for what
happens is the same as what actually
happens that's weak emergence okay weak
emergence is when in principle all the
behavior could have been figured out
just by putting the lower level laws on
a computer
and strong emergence is not that strong
emergence is defined as
something happens but it's not what you
would have predicted by putting the
lower level laws of physics on the
computer it's something else coming in
that is somehow brand new because it is
a collective okay so emmett what is what
emmett is getting at is that strong
emergence picture is kind of suggested
by this
motto of the holes greater than some of
its parts but it's vague enough that
you're not sure okay
so and and people so and i have a take
on this which is only temporary and i
don't want to you know completely um
uh by accident i'm still thinking about
this myself but
i think that whether or not strong
emergence happens at all
depends on what your two levels are okay
to a physicist like myself like the
microscopic level is going to be quantum
field theory or atoms or something like
that and in that case i think strong
emergence just doesn't happen
because we know what the lower level
things are they're pretty simple quantum
fields electrons particles or whatever
they obey local equations of motion what
happens to the electron is only
influenced by what's happening in its
immediate neighborhood of space and time
and there's just either
that theory the core theory is either
right or wrong
and if it's right then you don't have
strong emergence and if it's wrong then
good you win the nobel prize if you show
that it's wrong but no one has done that
yet okay
um
but
sometimes you're interested in cases
where the lower level theory
is not fundamental physics like what if
you want to say the behavior of a nation
emerges out of the behavior of its
citizens
okay
citizens bless their hearts so my
favorite friends are citizens but
they're not simple
they're themselves complex systems
so you can try to your best to invent
laws of behavior governing the citizens
the people in the country
but those laws are hard to pin down hard
to know that they're right and it's hard
to say that they're local
so it might very well be the case that
there's some useful sense in which you
get strong emergence when you connect
one complex level of analysis to another
higher but still complex level of
analysis whereas i don't think there's
any interesting emergence of strong
emergence if your lower level theory is
completely simple and local like physics
is
samine tajik says given my background in
quantum mechanics i was asked to work on
a mutual project regarding quantum
finance
the quantum part which involved bohmian
mechanics made sense for me in the math
was simple however when i start thinking
about the results and conclusion part i
suspect the whole idea
like how using quantum bohmian potential
one can talk about financial markets and
analyze the occurrence of rare events
sorry i me sean emphasized the wrong
pronunciation there
when i start thinking about the results
in conclusion part i suspect the whole
idea in other words suspicion is being
raised about the whole idea
so i remember how you posted this book
quantum social science written by the
same author i'm now working with here i
would really love to know your thoughts
on subjects like quantum finance and
quantum social science well you know as
someone who is trying to write a book
called the physics of democracy i cannot
completely poo poo the idea but you got
to be careful you know as i tried to say
when i was describing the physics of
democracy i'm a believer in using
insights from quantum or from physics
broadly and certainly inspiration and
analogies from physics when
understanding society or other things
but that's different than saying that it
is
that
in other words you know a financial
market or a country or whatever
they are not a way function they are not
a quantum state
you cannot just blindly apply all of the
knowledge that you get from thinking
about quantum mechanics to these other
kinds of situations
that's not to say you can't be inspired
by some of the behavior of quantum
systems especially because they're
probabilistic and so forth
probability works a little bit
differently in quantum mechanics than
classical mechanics so
very often
when people try
to apply quantum mechanics to other
kinds of systems i think that they're
just missing the fact that they could
equally well just talk about classical
probabilities since the systems are
looking at are really classical but i
don't know the specific examples you're
talking about so i can't judge so i
wouldn't
immediately dismiss it nor immediately
take it um
as as sensible i would really think
about whether or not uh you were getting
something extra out of
the fact that this was supposed to be a
truly quantum thing rather than just a
fancy and useless way of talking about
classical probability distributions
richard graf says in your conversation
with arie kirschenbaum on alien life
aside from a brief mention of possible
life in the clouds of venus there is no
discussion of the potential for life
based on the atmosphere of a planet is
there some fundamental obstacle that
would make atmospheric life especially
intelligent life highly unlikely without
some reliance on either the marine or
terrestrial environments
um well you're at you should ask arik
this not me uh but it's a good question
and i could easily imagine obstacles
to uh life becoming highly intelligent
and technological i mean look
intelligence is a different thing right
intelligence could i think arise
anywhere what do i know but that's what
i would suspect but technological is a
little bit different you know i do think
that you get extra flexibility and
possibility when you kind of live near
the triple point the triple point in in
chemistry being uh the conditions under
which uh certain things could be liquid
solid or gas now a real chemist says
the triple point happens when a single
thing like water can be liquid solid or
gas but forgetting about the single
thing the fact that life on earth has
access to
solids and liquids and gases is kind of
useful if you want to grow up to be a
technological civilization if you're
literally just in the clouds of venus if
you never go down to the ground
you don't have access to either liquid
or solid okay so your raw materials are
much more constrained
than they would be if you were down on
the ground so all else being equal i
think it's not a surprise
that we became technological here on
earth with access to all these different
possibilities and maybe it's less likely
if we're just floating gas bags on venus
or jupiter
amino asks a priority question we make
all possible choices at each decision
point somewhere in the quantum
multiverse and if so this has unsettling
implications for the importance of moral
action as others are always both
maximally helped or hurt by our actions
making moral choices meaningless have i
got the right idea or is there something
i'm missing that will save me from this
existentially troubling conclusion yes
there's something you're missing
which is that not all decisions are
equal okay i mean and i i know i've said
this many times and it's in my book but
maybe i don't say it loud enough because
people seem to always fall into the same
what i think is a mistake which is you
know if there is a
let's say there's an electron
okay and you're going to put it through
a stern gerlock apparatus this is for
physicists out there they know that
that's how we measure the spin of an
electron it can either be spin up or
spin down along some axis that you
measure it in
famously
if you prepare the electron so that its
spin is pointed in the x direction
and then you measure it along the z
direction okay a perpendicular axis so
if you measure the spin of an axis of an
electron along an axis perpendicular to
where its spin actually is
you have a 50 50 chance of measuring it
spin up or spin down
then you get two branches of the wave
function you have a reader a readout
apparatus that says up or down and now
you have two branches but it's crucially
crucially crucially crucially important
that i could
measure the spin of electron that was
only 0.0001 degrees away from the z-axis
in the first place
and in that case with overwhelming
probability i would measure it to be
what the spin mostly was mostly spin up
it's again crucially important if you're
an everettian
there are two branches after you do that
there's a spin-up branch and a spin down
down branch but they are not created
equal
they do not get equal probability they
do not get equal mattering if you're
thinking about you know utilitarianism
or morality or choices or anything like
that
lots of things happen in the ever-ready
and multiverse but they don't all count
equally
so maybe in some single universe model
if you thought well
if i do this it's a good thing and
that's good
then in an everetti model you think well
if i'm probably going to do this that's
a good thing and that's good and all the
meaningfulness is exactly still there
it's not changed whatsoever just because
of the existence of these very very very
tiny and completely ignorable other
worlds
john morgan says apologies that this is
answered elsewhere but why do
measurements of quantum states produce
definite outcomes i have a vague
recollection of an argument regarding
diagonalization of the density matrix
under measurement and maybe that's
related but this isn't the kind of thing
that's easily googled uh yes that's fair
enough uh it's not easily googled i mean
you can google it whether you're gonna
get a sensible answer is harder
so the answer depends a little bit there
is an answer uh the answer depends a
little bit on what we mean by produce
definite outcomes so there's two things
going on one is that when you measure a
quantum system what that means is
you bring your quantum system into
entanglement with an environment okay
and that in that induces branching of
the wave function of the universe as one
branch on which the system now has one
value and another branch is it another
value that's why you get definite
outcomes in the sense that there is one
value on one branch and another value on
another branch
now if you don't know anything about
decoherence or becoming entangled with
the environment that's a much longer
story i wrote a book you can buy it i
encourage you to do so but there is
another
question another issue here which is
maybe what you're actually getting at
which is why is it specific
definite outcomes so there's one fact
that a quantum measurement gets you an
outcome
the other fact is that the outcomes it
gets you are predictable ahead of time
and there's a very limited sample so
let's just take schrodinger's cat that's
what we always take it's a good example
in my version of schrodinger's cat the
cat is put into a superposition of awake
and asleep
and so in the formalism of quantum
mechanics you can observe the cat okay
and you can observe it along any basis
you want which is a way of saying that
you could ask the question is the cat
awake or asleep that's a question you
can ask with a two possible answers
awake or asleep and you will get a
definite answer
but there are other quantum states like
the superposition of a wake plus a sleep
and there's a perpendicular combination
the superposition of a wake minus asleep
the minus sign really makes a difference
and you can ask that question in
principle in principle you could say i
observe the cat to ask the question
is it in the superposition of one half
awake one over square root of two be
technical about it awake plus a sleep
or is it in the awake minus a sleep
state
nothing in the formalism of quantum
mechanics prevents you from asking that
question but in fact when you see cats
despite jokes
the real cats always either awake or
asleep you never see it in the
superposition of both and you cannot
even choose to see it in a superposition
of both so what's going on
and that is not just a coherence but the
feature of d coherence namely that the
interactions with the environment are
local in space when you talk about
decoherence and the entanglement with
the environment what you mean is
there are photons let's say in the box
with the cat
that will either interact with the cat
or not
depending on whether it's awake or
asleep by which what i mean is there's a
physical configuration of the cat we're
imagining that the awake cat is up and
walking around and the sleep cat is
lying on the floor sleeping okay that's
what we're imagining just because it's
our thought experiment we can set it up
however however we want and the point is
that a photon that might hit and be
absorbed by the cat if it were up and
walking around will miss the cat if it's
asleep and that's true for all the
photons right there's a coherent
physical spatial extent that the cat has
depending on whether it's awake or
asleep and it there is no coherent
physical extent it has if it's in a
superposition
so the fact that the cat is constantly
being bombarded by particles that
interact with it depending on where
the cat is
means that in practice you will always
observe the cat to be in a macroscopic
super in a macroscopically sensible
coherent state not in a superposition of
two such things so the bare formalism of
quantum mechanics that you might learn
about in a textbook
would not answer this question most
textbooks don't talk about decoherence
or pointer states as they are called or
anything like that but that is the
answer
now there's other answers there are
questions that that raises about why
interactions are like that etcetera
etcetera but that's basically the reason
there is a classical regime
that you get by focusing in on
states of quantum systems that are
macroscopically in certain places not
superpositions of being in different
places and those are the states we
actually see because that's how
decoherence works
to m says do you think the laws of
physics are universal do you think it i
think of the most basic law after all
we're assuming universality when probing
the universe with the web space
telescope right
well we're not assuming we're doing what
good scientists do we're hypothesizing
and we're testing that hypothesis so for
example you could very easily
hypothesize that
the
physics that give rise to atomic
transition lines which you can see in
the spectra of a galaxy the physics is
the same in a distant galaxy 5 billion
light years away as it is here
and then you can test that hypothesis
you can also hypothesize maybe it was
different
if the mass of the electron or if the
fine structure constant were slightly
different values then you would see
shifts
in the position
of spectral lines that we observe that's
what astronomers do all the time that's
how you figure out the redshift of a
distant galaxy you measure the positions
of its spectral lines
and those spectral lines will be moved
if the laws of physics were a little bit
different and there's two things to say
about that one is that the motion is not
uniform for different spectral lines so
you might say well how do you know if
it's been moved maybe that's just what
you're perceiving as the redshift but
the all the different there are many
different spectral lines and they all
rearrange with respect to each other in
different ways if you change the
underlying laws of physics so that's
different than a single universal
redshift put on top of everything
and the other thing is you might say
well that's if you change the laws of
physics a little bit what if you change
them a lot
well then if you change them a lot then
you don't expect to see spectral lines
at all maybe you have physics that
doesn't even give rise to what you and i
know of as spectral lines so
anyway the point is you're being a good
scientist you're
starting with a very simple hypothesis
very clean hypothesis that the laws of
physics that we observe here on earth
are the same far away and then you test
that hypothesis and so far
every little bit of testing we've done
whether it's for electromagnetism or for
the masses of particles or for the
strong interactions or whatever they've
all been consistent with the idea that
the laws of physics are the same very
far away
that has nothing to say about when
you're outside our observable horizon of
course the part of the universe we can't
see the laws of physics might very well
be different that possibility literally
is the cosmological multiverse we don't
know whether that's true or not
paul hess says my understanding is that
triggering a vacuum decay is a
probabilistic quantum event the higgs
field would have to quantum tunnel to a
new lower energy state with an extremely
tiny probability at each moment in space
time this might occur
if this is true then under the many
worlds interpretation would each moment
of time contain a branch with an
extremely thin new decayed world being
sliced off leaving the non-decayed
portion of what we continue to live in
that we can live in as getting
continually thinner over time uh yes i
think this might be the first time my
answer is shorter than the question that
is exactly what happens in many worlds
it's a smooth
evolution
from a wave function that says the
vacuum has not decayed to a
superposition of it has not decayed plus
it decayed at this point indicated at
this point it to get at this point for
every point in space and time where it
might have decayed
emil rojas says from a physics point of
view what is a dimension does it differ
in any way from the math notion
it differs in some ways of course
physicists use math so physicists use
the mathematical definition of of
dimension and and roughly speaking it's
actually kind of tricky to define
mathematically what dimension is but
it's a standard by which you're
measuring something and those standards
can be incommensurable in the sense we
were talking about earlier so you know
energy and length are incommensurable so
those are different dimensions for
quantities you might want to mention
in math it is most so we use the word
dimension slightly different senses both
in math and in physics
and math is very often to have
your attention focused on what is called
a manifold right a manifold is something
that
in very small regions looks smooth
uh maybe i should start maybe we should
back up you start with geometry and flat
geometry okay euclidean geometry and in
euclidean geometry it's very easy to
distinguish between one-dimensional
geometry two-dimensional geometry
three-dimensional geometry etc
a manifold is a generalization of that
notion that says in small regions of the
manifold it looks like euclidean
geometry with some definite dimension
so if something is a manifold in the
math definition it has a dimensionality
everywhere it doesn't change its
dimensionality anywhere
of course that is exactly the same
notion of dimension that physicists use
when talking about space-time because
space-time is a dimension so it is
nothing more or less than the number of
independent by independent we mean
perpendicular
directions in which you can move so you
can move forward backward
up down
left right for example three possible
directions because the direction and
minus the direction count the same i
think that's pretty much the same notion
uh in both physics and math physicists
often use this you know um unit idea of
dimension like i mentioned energy time
length
temperature things like that are
quantities that have units and that's
also sometimes called a dimension but
it's it's very very related to the math
notion
gregory kusnick says will you be
teaching any online courses at hopkins
or otherwise making course materials
available to the general public
i don't think the courses are online as
far as i know but i don't know i'm not
there yet so maybe and who knows also
about the future but generally whenever
i have a course i put on you know like
either lecture notes or supplementary
materials or something in fact you can
go to my website and find
such things for various courses that
i've already done in the past look
they're generally not very good
they're generally you know handwritten
or whatever kind of sloppy i mean i i
shouldn't even say generally um
the last time i taught a course was at
caltech i taught quantum mechanics
uh the third
quarter of a three-quarter quantum
mechanics course and i put all my
lecture notes online in handwritten form
because it was easy to do so
because my handwritten lecture notes
were actually done on an ipad and so
it's easy to turn them into pdfs and put
them online
for the seminars that's not a an e as
easy a thing to do it doesn't make quite
as much sense this is a lecture course
and so i just put my lecture notes
online whereas seminars don't have
lecture notes you're supposed to be
having the students uh do most of the
talking or even if i'm talking it will
be in response to something that is
organically happening in the class
discussion but there will still be
a web page for every course that has
readings and things like that you know
syllabus and so forth i think that's
easy to put online but i don't think
there'll be any videotaping going on
which you know look probably
that's good for a lecture course
videotaping and putting online makes
perfect sense i actually tried to get my
quantum mechanics course videotaped and
put online at caltech it didn't happen
one of the reasons i became frustrated
at caltech they were not interested in
doing that but for a seminar it doesn't
make sense for a seminar you want it to
be about that moment it's not just
wisdom being handed down from the
lecture it's the conversation that is
going on that is more important
christopher matthews says have you ever
gotten into formula one racing with a
huge role of aerodynamics in it i can't
think of another sport where the study
of physics plays a larger part
so two answers here one is a short
answer no i don't really know anything
about formula one racing uh i do know i
have a friend deandra leslie pilecki
who's a physicist who wrote a book
called the physics of nascar where she
actually digs into the physics of car
racing in general nascar in particular
not the same as formula one but but
related i think um so you can check that
out if you're interested i agree that
there's a lot of physics going on but
the second part of my answer is it's not
my kind of physics and i don't say that
in any way disparagingly it's exactly
the opposite when you try to apply
physics to the real world
suddenly all of the complications of the
real world generally become important
especially with something like formula
one racing you're absolutely right
there's a lot of physics involved but
the physics involved is not the kind of
physics where you can spherical cow your
way out of the complications where you
can ignore friction things like that or
look at the elementary particles and get
anything like that so that's that's much
harder than what i do for a living and
so i don't pretend to be an expert on it
alexandre zani says
it seems like we humans experience the
universe in a particular basis moving in
time looking at things in 3d position
not frequency et cetera do you think
it's likely that there is a similarly
interesting structure in other bases
my guess is no actually my guess is that
when you say that we i agree with the
presumption of the question we humans
experience the universe in a certain
kind of
configuration that we pay attention to
certain variables are those that are
observable to us
in the low energy coarse grained world
and others are not okay
we see positions most obviously and
that's in part because as we said
earlier
physics has interactions that are local
in position not in momentum or anything
like that and i think of this as a
feature of emergence right there is a
higher level emergent structure that uh
supervenes on the lower level goings-on
and i think that those emergent
structures you know they have a life of
their own even though they could in
principle be derived from the lower
level structure the point is you don't
have to derive them okay that's what
emergence is to me if i didn't know
that my table was made of atoms i could
still talk about the table and its
solidity and its height and its color
and its weight and so forth okay it's
compatible with the underlying structure
but i don't need to know about the
underlying structure to make sense of it
and i think that the existence of such
higher level structures what dan denik
calls real patterns
is rare i don't think that there's many
many different sets of real patterns
that are useful i think they're precious
and and few in the set of all possible
ways to coarse grain the underlying
goings-on because the point is not only
can i look at and see
the features of the table in front of me
but i can use that information to make
predictions right i can predict that if
i put the coffee cup down it will set
itself down on the table without falling
through i can predict if i try to pick
up this table with one hand i will fail
there's an enormous amount of predictive
structure inherent in that pattern with
very little information i don't need to
know almost anything about the
individual atoms making up the table
right that's the wonderfulness of a
higher level emergent structure gives
you an enormous handle on the world on
the basis of very little input data and
i think that's very very rare in the
space of all possible things to imagine
bases if you will in your language to
imagine observing the thing in
rue phillips says listening to previous
podcasts i've gotten the sense that you
suspect a world that largely rejected
gods and superstitions would ultimately
be preferable to all rather than one
that does not
the reason being a world that pursues
and accepts truth is typically better
off for a variety of reasons do i have
your thinking right and if so could you
elaborate on the costs you have in mind
of having gods and superstitions as part
of society in our modern age
i mean i think that's partly right you
know i wouldn't necessarily put in
exactly those words i am in favor of
truth
i suspect that everyone is in favor of
truth at least for themselves you know
people might not be in favor of other
people having the truth that happens all
the time but they want themselves to
have the truth i don't know of anybody
who actually says i would rather be
wrong about the world than be right
about it right and therefore the fact
that i don't think that gods and
superstitions are
correct truthful descriptions of the
world means that i would rather not only
myself but other people understand that
and and accept it
i've also been very very clear that the
empirical
implications and consequences of
religious belief are messy there are
good aspects and bad aspects if you said
well is it mostly good or mostly bad i
would have no idea how to start
answering that question
it's very easy to point to individual
really good things or individual really
bad things and ignore the others and
therefore think you're winning the
argument i don't think that there's a
rigorous way of weighing all of them i
can sort of mildly casually suspect
that in the modern world those
implications and consequences are mostly
negative but i can't really back that up
with a calculation or with evidence
the one thing i would point to is you
know we do in our world have
morals we have ethics we have rules for
behavior
what we don't have is an agreed upon way
of getting them or justifying them right
so we kind of agree that some things are
right and some things are wrong as a
society we are very bad at actually
justifying why this thing is right and
this thing is wrong we sort of
appeal to
um
just insistence right just like you must
know this is right that or then that is
wrong and so forth like you go to the
obvious examples and try to agree on
that
and different people have either
objective moral realists they're
subjective moral people you know et
cetera et cetera et cetera
certainly for many many people the
justification for their moral beliefs
comes from some religious belief and i
think those justifications fail because
i don't believe i don't accept the moral
the religious starting point that they
have
i really think
that when it comes to ethics and
morality we would have a much better
conversation if we started by admitting
that we live in a natural universe
rather than a supernatural one and a lot
of that was you know evidenced in my
book the big picture i try to put
forward exactly that um idea so i think
that's probably you know in in thinking
about ethics morality is probably where
our current society
falls the most obviously short of where
i would like them to fall if everyone
was being a naturalist
chris shipton says
it seems as if humans
sorry it seems as humans that our
knowledge of the universe is increasing
but the universe is on a path toward the
state of highest entropy in the far
future will there be a time that if
there are humans we will be unable to
gain new knowledge or make accurate
predictions i think the parentheses
there are the important part there won't
be humans eventually there will be a
time when there are no humans
so but there is something interesting
going on here yes
of course entropy is increasing and as
far as we know it's just going to keep
increasing until it sort of levels off
it asymptotes to some maximum value at
least within any observable part of the
universe
things like knowledge
are temporary okay there's no knowledge
at the big bang because there's no
agents having any knowledge there's no
knowledge in the far far future because
there's no agents around everything is
in thermal equilibrium it's on that
journey between the big bang in the far
far future that agents come into
existence with a property one can call
knowledge of the rest of the world
some correlations between data in
side themselves
memories
laws of physics knowledge etc and what
happens out there in the world this is a
temporary feature that is enabled by the
fact that entropy is increasing uh but
it's also going to be disabled by the
fact that entropy continues to increase
so the reason why that's important is
because it's easy to say entropy is
increasing it's hard to say exactly the
way in which entropy increases and what
are all the steps along the way and what
are all the implications of that
you might remember that scott aronson
and i and some students in postdocs
wrote a paper about the emergence and
then disappearance of complexity
in a closed thermodynamic system
i'm still thinking about that stuff in
fact i was talking about it with people
at sfi
this last three weeks when i was there
and there's a lot to be done about the
emergence of these words like knowledge
and prediction as temporary features of
a universe going from low entropy to
high entropy it's not something i don't
think is very well understood right now
vladimir bellic says in your oral
history interview when talking about
your high school years
you mentioned that you weren't good at
giving talks back then i'm also not a
natural at this i get similar comments i
use too many words to convey a thought
and i stumble a lot
i'm currently trying to get better at
speaking because i'm starting an
educational youtube channel for my
business soon do you have any advice on
how to improve at talking to an audience
that might be helpful to me and any
other listeners with a similar
aspiration
um
it's an excellent question a very very
important question
i don't have super good advice here i
will i'll mention two things
that are true but i'm not sure how
helpful they are
one thing is practice
do it a lot right i mean the context in
which i was talking about not being good
at giving talks
was that i was on the speech team speech
and debate team in high school and
uh
there's an irony and that i was on the
speech team and i was very bad at giving
speeches but that's how i got better at
it by just doing it a lot and doing it
not just
you know
thoughtlessly but thoughtfully mindfully
thinking about what was working what was
not working
look there are plenty of people out
there who can listen to you give a talk
and tell you
what's going right and what's going
wrong it's hard to listen to them right
it's hard to take their advice to heart
and really change yourself and work at
changing but that's what you could try
to do
the other
piece of advice again not necessarily
very helpful is i don't know
your personal style but there are a lot
of people who
are relatively
fluid and articulate when talking in
conversation
and then when you put them in front of a
formal crowd they become stilted and
boring and unnatural
and
why is that like it's a whole nother
thing like some people just are always
tilted and boring that's too bad but
again you can work at that through
practice but some people are different
levels of interestingness depending on
whether it's a informal conversation or
a formal presentation
if that's the case then you can
certainly just internally work at
making your mode of presentation not
different
when you're giving a formal presentation
then when you're having an informal
conversation you can think about why is
it different i've seen people you know
because i hang out with journalists
sometimes i've seen examples of people
being interviewed
and you know before the tape starts
rolling they're joking around with the
interviewer and they're very clear and
charming and articulate and then as soon
as
they're being recorded they stiffen up
right and they get all very formal and
and less articulate and less interesting
and that's what i was like um when i was
giving talks as a high school student so
that's one trick anyway that you can
think about think of it more as
how you would speak during a
conversation tell some jokes be relaxed
don't tell too many jokes depending on
how your joke telling skills go but that
kind of mode is what you should try to
think about being in
peter solfest says if gravity can be
derived from entropy doesn't that mean
it's an emergent property that can be
ejected from our fundamental ontology
if that's the case why is quantum
gravity even necessary
yes if gravity can be derived from
entropy which is that's that statement
is a bit of exaggeration gravity can't
be derived from entropy but it might
have something to do with entropy there
might be a derivation that uses entropy
in a central way that gets you to
gravity okay and if that's true
that does mean it's emergent phenomenon
it does mean it can be ejected from our
fundamental ontology it doesn't mean
it's not necessary
you know as i like to say there's no
human being in the world that lives at
the level of our fundamental ontology
right just the word human being
doesn't exist in the level of our
fundamental ontology
uh we live at a higher level you know we
live in a world where we can see certain
things where we can predict certain
things where we can interact with
certain things none of which are from
our higher level our fundamental
ontology desk in front of me classic
example that i've viewed several times
already in this ama
so we would like to understand that you
know just i would like to understand how
airplanes fly
i would like to understand quantum
gravity how it emerges from these lower
levels there's more to life than the
most fundamental ontology we have
brendan says i was watching your 2015
god and cosmology debate with william
lane craig a few weeks ago given the
past seven years since the debate has
there been any scientific breakthroughs
or experiences that you would now
include in your talking points for
naturalism
short answer is no uh i don't think that
there's been any scientific
breakthroughs or experiences um if i
were to do it again which i have no
plans to do right now but you never know
um probably my specific talking points
would be different just because i've you
know changed a little bit i've uh
written the book the big picture since
then i think the big picture was after
2015 wasn't i think so yes
um
so i've thought about these issues a
little bit more carefully in certain
ways um you know about the pros and cons
of naturalism you know i've dwelt on and
talked with other people et cetera et
cetera so none of the specifics would be
the same just like we all change over
time but not because of any scientific
breakthroughs i mean look to be super
duper honest
i don't think it's a close call right
between naturalism and supernaturalism
naturalism and theism i think that you
know sometime around the 19th century
was the last time when one could really
say well you know maybe theism but i'm
not sure you know by now it's pretty
clear so i don't expect ongoing
scientific research to have any big
impact
on
that set of points of view i have unless
they actually are evidence for theism
which would change my mind by a lot but
i haven't seen any of that in the last
seven years
chris murray says
the holographic principle is reminiscent
of the fact that in complex analysis a
holomorphic function on a disk is fully
determined by its values on the boundary
of the disk do you think this is an
important connection or just a cosmetic
resemblance so the idea here for those
of you who are not
complex analysis experts
is that there's a certain so in in
complex analysis what are you talking
about you have a complex number you have
the set of all complex numbers the set
of all complex numbers is kind of like
the plane right the two-dimensional
plane x and y-axes
likewise the comp a single complex
number has two parts it has the real
part and the imaginary part so the set
of all complex numbers topologically
it's a plane we talk about the complex
plane
and we can have a function of that plane
so it's a function of the real part and
the imaginary part of where you are on
the plane and generally we think about
complex functions on the complex plane
so we map a complex number to another
complex number okay there's a certain
subset of those functions called
holomorphic
uh there's mathematical conditions you
can google them that will tell you what
a homomorphic function is and those
conditions are pretty restrictive you
know most functions are not holomorphic
but some are
and a nice feature of holomorphic
functions is that it's so restrictive
that if you just tell me if you have
like some circle okay on in the complex
plane and you think about the function
being defined inside the circle that's
the disk inside the circle
then just telling me what the function
is on the boundary
on the circle that you've drawn is
enough to completely specify what the
function is inside on the disk
that's that does bear a family
resemblance to holography right the
holographic principle in black hole
physics is supposed to be that the
entire interior state of the black hole
can be thought of in terms of
information living on the boundary on
the event horizon of the black hole
and it's not actually
a feature you know this feature that um
a higher dimensional set of things
is determined by a lower dimensional set
of things is true in both those cases
but also is true much more widely like
you all know a very simple example of
this namely physics
if i give you a physical situation at a
moment in time
that's enough to determine what happens
in the future if it's deterministic
physics it's newtonian physics or the
schrodinger equation or whatever as well
as in the past you're determining a
whole space times worth a whole four
dimensional worth of solution to an
equation just from a three-dimensional
slice of time amount of information so
when you have some constraint
like holomorphicity or the equations of
motion of physics it's very common it's
not magical or weird to get a full extra
dimensions worth of dependence out of
initial information
so that's the sense in which there is a
family resemblance it's not a very close
sense the the interior of black hole is
not the complex plane in fact it's in
the in the macroscopic world in which we
live is three-dimensional not
two-dimensional so it can't be exactly
the same thing
having said that there is a slightly
similar feature that is not a
holomorphic function but but a related
feature which is that if you have
something like gravity or
electromagnetism you have gauss's law
okay that's a way of saying the
following thing if i
tell you
[Music]
let's put it this way let's say the
collection of charged particles it's
actually easier to visualize for
electric charge than for gravity but it
also works for gravity if i have a
collection of charged particles protons
let's say and there's no electron so
it's just protons
and i know that these electrons these
protons rather are in some region of
space
then what gauss's law tells me is that
if i look at the electric field on the
boundary of that region so i have some
spherical boundary
surrounding you know the surface of the
sphere the
surrounding what we call in math the
ball which is the interior of the sphere
the the statement of gauss's law is that
i can integrate up the electric field on
the sphere the boundary and that tells
me the amount of charge inside inside
the ball so we can figure out a lot
about the distribution of charges inside
just by thinking just by measuring the
electric field on the boundary maybe
even not just the total charge but a
little bit about the distribution of
charges by looking at where the electric
field is stronger or weaker on the
boundary
we can't learn everything about the
charge distribution inside because if
you have a charge distribution that
itself is perfectly spherical
then the size of that sphere is
completely irrelevant it's going to give
you the same electric field outside
so in conventional and again the same
thing exactly exactly happens for
gravity
so
conventionally you can learn a lot about
the gravitational or electric charges
inside a region by looking at the
associated fields on the boundary
but not everything this has to do with
the fact that it's a long-range field a
gage field there's symmetries etcetera
etcetera
you would like
to promote that to something like what
we think of as the holographic principle
believe me people have thought about
this uh it hasn't quite
turned into a rigorous careful
identification
for example for reasons like if you have
a spherically symmetric distribution
then it should look the same outside uh
but maybe there's something there maybe
there's something that is in the
connection between long-range fields and
boundaries that that sounds kind of
holographic on the other hand you know
i kind of think
that that's kind of too cheap and easy
that there is something really non-local
going on in gravity because of how
gravity is involved with the curvature
of space-time that gives rise to this
holographic effect um but we'll have to
see this is a very good question you
know you're on the right track thinking
about things like this
jace forbes asks a priority question if
black hole's
gravity caused time dilation and hawking
radiation causes the black hole to
evaporate would the time dilation seem
to accelerate this evaporation from the
perspective of an infalling particle and
why if time dilation approaches zero
could the said particle fall into a
black hole before it evaporates
completely so i think your first half
and second half of questions i'll allow
you the two questions
but they're different questions okay um
you know from the perspective and
involving particle it's actually really
subtle and interesting and i am not
going to claim i understand it correctly
you know usually when i say i don't
understand something correctly
it's because either no one understands
it correctly or because someone does but
i haven't tried
this is something that i think is
understandable and i have tried a little
bit but i'm still confused about what
happens from the perspective of an
informing observer when you cross the
black hole event horizon
roughly speaking we know what happens
which is that when you're far away you
see
hawking radiation
if you start falling in
okay
you'll see a slightly blue shifted
hawking radiation you're going to see it
you're moving now toward the black hole
so the radiation you see seems to get
more energetic in some sense
but if you keep falling in as you cross
the event horizon you don't see anything
at all
because from your point of view the
event horizon is not a special place so
somehow you have to sort of be feeling
or noticing the black hole as an object
rather than being so close up that it
almost becomes indistinguishable to you
uh somehow that's how the vacuum of the
quantum field theory works that it looks
like empty space right there at the
horizon and looks like there's a
radiating black hole when you're very
far away so that's the first part of the
question the second part
if time dilation approaches zero could
said particle fall into a black hole
before it evaporates completely yes
that's an easy one you can do that
calculation uh it's a little bit subtle
because
when you have a black hole that doesn't
evaporate you have an ordinary general
relativity black hole like you'll read
about in my textbook or whatever
there's the event horizon right and the
event horizon is well defined we know
where it is and it's a global property
the event horizon is the point of no
return it's the point past which if you
go inside you can never come out
if you let the black hole evaporate
in some sense everything that goes in
comes out okay we don't understand that
sense completely but the same amount of
energy the same amount of matter that
goes in comes out ideally we hope the
same amount of information okay so there
is no event horizon really for an
evaporating black hole so that
complicates things what can you do what
you can do is you can define an apparent
horizon there's a way without making
reference to the future evaporation of
the black hole there's a way of saying
you know roughly speaking the radius of
the black hole in a short shield metric
that a non-charged non-spinning black
hole is a known quantity 2g m where 2 is
2 g is newton's constant m is the mass
of the black hole so you can just draw a
sphere at a radius of 2gm and say that's
apparently where the horizon is now okay
and in that sense that's where the
hawking radiation is coming from and yes
particles can pass in pass by that
apparent horizon no problem uh long
before the black hole evaporates i mean
when you think about it it doesn't take
long to fall into a black hole but it
takes a huge amount of time for black
holes to evaporate so that's that's what
you would expect
christophe piernonski peronski says i
still don't get how creativity invention
discovery and eureka moments are all
possible in the fully deterministic
block universe they all seem like
theater in this context what am i
missing
well uh i guess you're missing something
subtle in the definition of creativity
invention and discovery
i mean you seem to be smuggling in to
the definition of these uh
human-sounding words something that is
intrinsically non-physical or you know
non-deterministic somehow but look
you can recognize creativity right
you can look at someone's work and say
oh that's very creative you made a
discovery you made an invention
and then god shows up and god says you
know what the laws of physics are
deterministic
why would that change your opinion about
whether or not that work of art or
science was a creative or a discovery or
whatever right this is how higher level
emergent phenomena work at the level of
the core theory of physics there are no
fundamental words called creativity
invention or discovery there's just
this quantum state of the universe
evolving forward according to the
schrodinger equation
exactly as for laplace's demon
in a classical context applause's demon
knows where all the particles are and
where they're going
there's no such thing as temperature
pressure entropy any of those things
because you know where all the particles
are it's only when you have incomplete
information at the higher level that it
becomes useful and interesting to talk
about temperature and pressure and so
forth likewise it's only when you're
talking about the human level
not the fully deterministic fundamental
physics level that it's useful to talk
about creativity invention discovery etc
those levels the best descriptions we
have or will ever have are not
deterministic
you're not going to get a deterministic
theory of human beings that it that
involves only
knowable things about those human beings
and that's okay just like
flipping a coin seems to be
non-deterministic to us even though uh
we think that if we knew the exact micro
state of the coin and the your thumb and
whatever you could figure it out
you could predict exactly what was going
to happen
owen asks just wondering why anyone at
all accepts the post-human commonplace
that you can't or shouldn't derive an
ought from an is if aunts aren't to be
derived from isis how should they be
derived well you know it depends on your
attitude towards odds uh
the fact that you can't derive odds from
is is
is just logic there's literally nothing
other than that i can write down a set
of axioms or postulates or premises
all of which say this is true this is
true this is true
conclusion
this ought to be true you can't do that
it's just literally impossible simply as
a matter of logic
you can do it if you smuggle in to your
premises some ought some statement about
well that all not to be true that sounds
bad let's not do it you know or you can
usually the way that people pretend to
get around the odd is problem is they
fake language right you know they
prevaricate or equivocate i should say
about the meanings of words you know you
can say it is true that i don't want
this to be happening therefore i should
not let it happen therefore i ought not
to let it happen but you see you you're
sort of just cheating in natural
language you're not actually deriving
anything uh sensible so
if you want to know where the odds come
from i mean strictly speaking they're
not derived that's the answer there is
no moral realism
there is no objective fact about what
ought to be done
what you can do which i advocate doing
is saying that okay there are subjective
claims that i can make as a human being
i have things that i want to be true i
have ways that i want people to behave
etc and i'm going to
in concert with other people talking to
them and thinking about what they have
to say i'm going to propose that we use
the following regulations as moral
guidelines
you're not deriving them from anything
at all you're postulating them on the
basis of what you want to be true that's
what moral constructivism is all about
and i think that's the truth that's the
way the world actually works again if
you think of what people actually do
it's that
they then justify it in all sorts of
fancy philosophical ways but really they
have some feeling about how they would
like things to be and then they justify
it but that's not really a derivation
fabian rosedalen says what is your
relationship to visual art paintings
digital or not do you paint have you
ever tried painting do you have any
favorite artists or style um a big fan
of visual arts you know i have art books
lying around the house etc
not an expert not like super
knowledgeable when i was a here's
something you might not know when i was
a postdoc at the institute for
theoretical physics at uc santa barbara
one of the uh famous physicists there is
gary horowitz string theorist gravity
person
and his wife corrine was the education
director for the uc santa barbara art
museum
so she ran a program where undergraduate
students could work as docents at the
art museum they could you know give
tours and explain things to people and
so even though i was not an
undergraduate student i was a postdoc i
signed up to be a docent uh with corrine
horowitz and she loved having me because
most of the young undergraduate docents
were women which they actually were way
ahead of me in knowing about art but i
was way ahead of them because i had a
very deep voice
and the kids who would come on you know
elementary school kindergarten trips to
the art museum were much more willing to
listen to me because i had a deeper
sounding voice so i commanded respect
among the ten-year-olds who would come
to the art museum even though i knew
less about what i was talking about you
didn't have to know that much to be a
docent just you know give an
entertaining and mostly truthful
exposition of what was going on
all of which is to say i i like art
quite a bit i'm a big fan even though
not perfectly knowledgeable um i have
even tried to paint i have even painted
it's been a long time since i've
actually actively done it so i can't
claim that i am a painter but you know
my formative experience was going to a
modern art museum
having the reaction that many people
have using looking at these very
abstract kind of color field paintings
and saying well i can do that
and then but because i'm me i also said
well look if i'm gonna say i can do that
that's meaningless unless i do it right
let's actually do it and you know i
bought an easel and some canvases and
some acrylics acrylics are just easier
to deal with than oils if you're an
amateur
um and then you paint and you realize oh
guess what i can't do that
it's actually harder than it looks to
achieve the effect that a really good
abstract artist achieves so my respect
for the art form went up a lot uh i wish
i did more painting um we don't quite
have you know the sort of space
in the house right now maybe i will when
i get to baltimore maybe we'll fire up
the old painting studio again who knows
you never know and then i can sell them
as nfts or something like that and
retire that'd be awesome
james dencaro says do magnetic monopoles
actually exist and is it possible for us
to create them in a particle accelerator
or some other way how much energy would
it take to create one if this is even a
possibility
we don't know whether monopoles exist
there is uh they could exist
theoretically so by which i mean we can
construct physical theories
that are compatible with all the physics
that we know in the world and allow for
the existence of magnetic monopoles in
fact famously grand unified field
theories generally predict monopoles a
grand unified field theory is one that
unifies not just electricity magnetism
with the weak force like we have in the
electro weak theory but also with the
strong nuclear force
grand unification has nothing to do with
gravity i know that the terminology can
be a bit hard to follow sometimes but
literally the
strictly speaking defined word within
the physics community for grand unified
theory is strong weak and
electromagnetism combined together
theories along these lines were proposed
especially in 1970s sheldon glashow and
howard georgia started that trend but
many other people proposed different
models and there's a really interesting
mathematical fact the whole point of
a grand unified theory is that these
theories that we have strong weak
electromagnetic are gauge theories so
they're based on some symmetry group
and why do you see separate forces well
because the symmetry has been broken
that's why you see separate
electromagnetic and weak forces because
the symmetry between them was broken by
the higgs field
so grand unification imagines a bigger
symmetry group but still what we call a
simple group usually not always and
simple in this case is not just a
feeling that you have it's a technical
term in mathematics the a simple group
is a particular type of
continuous symmetry group
so if you combine the su3 su 2 and u1 of
the standard model of particle physics
into a single simple symmetry group
and then you break
that symmetry down to what we observe
su3 goes as you cross u1 then you
inevitably get magnetic monopoles
that's kind of cool right that's kind of
a cool result you cannot i mean it's a
predictive thing you cannot wiggle out
of it of course you can wiggle out of it
by making a not simple group or
something like that but there is that
conditional statement so that's a
remarkable statement and then it also
comes with a prediction
namely that the mass of the magnetic
monopole particles should be of order
the energy scale at which grand
unification happens
so if you think about protons and
neutrons live in an energy scale of
about one gev one billion electron volts
uh higgs boson top quark are 100 gev or
a little bit more so 10 to the 2 gev
grand unification is probably up at 10
to the 16 gev
way way higher than we're looking at
right now in particle accelerators the
large hadron collider is at 10 tev that
is a 10 000 gev
10 to the 4 gev still way short of 10 to
the 16.
so maybe you say well okay you're
predicting magnetic monopoles but i can
never make them
right so who cares
well if you're careful my caltech
colleague john preschool and others
pointed out that in the early universe
where the energies were very high you
should make a lot of magnetic monopoles
and in fact you can predict using a
mechanism called the kibble mechanism
after british physicist tom kibble you
can predict a minimum number of magnetic
monopoles that you had better make
and it turns out to be way bigger than
we're allowed to have we would have
easily noticed this the overall majority
of matter in the universe would be in
the form of magnetic monopoles if this
story were true
so people caught on to this in the late
1970s after
grand unification came along people
predicted there should be monopoles
uh people predicted that they should be
abundant and
they're not what's going on and secretly
that fact that puzzle was the primary
motivation for alan guth pursuing the
idea of the inflationary universe
scenario
these days magnetic monopoles are less
popular well i should say grand unified
theories are less popular they're not
unpopular
but they did make one other besides
monopoles they made one other prediction
which is that the proton should not be
perfectly stable it should decay
sadly there's like wiggle room in
exactly how fast it should decay but for
most of the plausible parameter space
again we should have seen them decay
most grand unified theories in their
simplest forms predict we should have
already seen proton decay we haven't
so grand unified theories have therefore
lowered in their bayesian credence by a
little bit and therefore the motivation
of getting rid of the monopoles the
so-called cosmological monopole problem
is less now than it used to be and so
when people talk about inflation now
they talk about the horizon problem the
flatness problem roughly speaking the
smoothness of the early universe
but the monopole problem is still there
if you want because grand unification is
still possible so that's a good
motivation for inflation roughly
inflation can inflate away the monopoles
you just have monopoles but there's less
than one per observable volume of the
universe that's why we've never seen
them
david poole asks a priority question
it's been stated that early proponents
of the copenhagen interpretation were
not interested in what was actually
happening during the coherence with the
statement shut up and calculate however
with the many worlds interpretation it
seems to me you are equally dismissive
when you say the world just evolves
according to the schrodinger equation
what does this actually mean
how does say a 60 probability evolve
into the real world that we observe
you know i don't think i'm dismissive
i think i have a theory that says
that the world evolves according to the
schrodinger equation you can be
dismissive of
questions you can think of questions not
interesting and dismiss it but
this is just a proposed theory of how
the physical world works you can't be
dismissive of it you can agree with it
or disagree with it or assign a credence
to it so my theory of the fundamental
dynamics of the physical world is it
evolves according to the schrodinger
equation
uh what does it actually mean it means
exactly that doesn't mean anything
different it means that there is a state
that is an element of hilbert space
it evolves according to an equation that
was written down by professor
schroedinger you say how does a sixty
percent probability evolve into the real
world well you're already not being a
good ever eddie and by saying how does a
60 probability evolve there's a wave
function that evolves not a probability
what you need to do is follow the
evolution of the wave function then then
ask why does it appear to us in the
world as if quantum mechanical events
happen with probabilities rather than
deterministically and the answer there
is as we discussed earlier because there
are different branches on which
different things happen
so they're different definite
experimental outcomes but those branches
are not created equally okay they have
different amplitudes uh associated with
them and you can ask there's a much
longer conversation again i did write a
book about this that you're welcome to
check out
but you can ask if i'm an agent if i'm a
person in one of these branches of the
wave function and i don't know whether
i'm going to be on the spin up branch or
the spin down branch is there a way
to assign probabilities that makes sense
then you have to define what it means to
make sense and so forth one of the
criteria is that it's consistent over
time you know things that people are
doing over there in their
experimental laboratories on alpha
centauri are not affecting the
probabilities that i would predict here
on earth
and therefore what happens is that you
get the right answer the the answer is
the only way to assign probabilities in
this world of being on one branch or the
other is what we call the born rule the
probability is the wave function squared
so it's not a probability
that is built into frequencies in the
world it's a probability of this
subjective that comes out of our
trying our best to figure out where we
are in the world but it does get you the
right answer
weston manville says how do you perceive
for a lack of better words the beginning
of everything and anything given all the
amazing experience and knowledge you
possess both philosophical and technical
i would just simply love to hear how you
may describe or conceptualize that which
is understandably beyond human
comprehension
is the beginning of something a false
concept when you trace it back to the
beginning to the series of events that
are responsible for its existence all
the way back to beyond the beginning of
the universe and time only as we know it
so as usual there's a few things going
on here in this question um i am someone
who believes and again i'll just say it
again because i always get uh accused of
dismissing things or of thinking that
things are certain even though i'm
trying to assign probabilities this is
what i think
at a certain level of credence i could
be wrong okay
but with all that said i think that the
laws of physics don't have a fundamental
direction of time built into them
so i don't think that we
have to think about
the current state of the world as
originating in the beginning then
flowing in to the current state what we
should think about is the whole history
of the world including the beginning and
now and the future
obeying the laws of physics in some way
now we don't know among and this is
something that it's not just i don't
know for sure but i have strong opinions
we truly don't know
with any strong confidence whether the
universe had a beginning or not that is
to say whether a physical clock
measuring proper time that you extended
back into the past would reach a point
where there was no past earlier than
that
or whether it could continue forever we
don't know that there are perfectly
respectable models
that have that go either way that have
either property um now but you're
completely right
about human comprehension and there's
there's a good news bad news situation
here
the bad news is that the kinds of things
happening at the beginning of our
universe let's call the big bang the
beginning whether or not it really was
right at the the beginning of our
comprehension of the universe
those things are very far removed from
human experience uh it's a different
kind of thing
happening
it's not something which our experience
growing up as people in the world has
equipped us to talk about much less
understand okay
and in fact as a practical matter that
lack of
um
straightforward comprehensibility and
discussion for that matter
gets in the way it makes us make
statements that you know upon further
careful reflection just aren't very
sensible and we sometimes
as mere finite human beings we lapse
into our everyday way of thinking about
the world even in regimes where we
shouldn't okay
that's the bad news the good news is
man if you're at all fair about it
the remarkable thing is not our lack of
comprehension but the presence of our
comprehension right the uh remarkable
thing is how much of the world we have
come to understand i have no idea what
fraction of it is
so i have no idea how much of
understanding the world we have versus
how much remains yet to be discovered so
i'm making not a relative state
statement about the fraction that we
know but just a list of things that we
know is to me utterly amazing when you
think about relativity and quantum
mechanics in the big bang not to mention
darwinian evolution of molecular biology
and sociology and psychology etc we've
learned an enormous amount just in a
couple hundred years we live in a 14
billion year old universe and in 200
years maybe let's give let's give it 500
or 5 000 years doesn't matter it's a
short period of time under which we've
really been carefully using the
scientific method thinking about the
universe and not only do we understand a
lot of it
we understand it in terms of highly
non-intuitive things like relativity the
big bang quantum mechanics most of all
but we get it we're able to do it
we use math we use philosophy we use
rigor we use data we use bayesian
updating all that stuff and using these
tools as leverage we were able to
develop enormous amounts of
understanding and best of all
when things are really going well
not only can we understand things but we
can know where our understanding fails
we can understand that you know i can
extrapolate beyond a certain point
but it's just guessing after that you
know we're not very very certain that's
why i can say with confidence that we
are not confident about whether the
universe had a beginning
we have data we have empirical
phenomenological information
about what the universe was doing a
minute after the big bang okay the big
bang you know that would be there if
general relativity were right which it's
not etcetera etcetera but hopefully you
know what i mean
but that's an enormous distance from our
everyday experience we understand what
the universe was doing i've written
papers about this myself we understand
the expansion rate and the density of
the universe a minute after the big bang
the temperature and to a very strong
uh
level the composition of the universe
and
we don't understand what it was doing a
microsecond after the big bang we just
don't we talk about it all the time as
working cosmologists
but we know that our knowledge is given
out which to me is as impressive as the
fact that we have that knowledge in the
first place
uh so what i suspect now let me just get
a little more poetic around it that i'm
trying to be a good scientist there and
saying we don't know
what happened at the beginning um
i don't think that what happened at the
beginning is beyond human comprehension
i think it's different than our everyday
experience sure
uh but i don't think that it is
ineffable i do not think that it is
beyond our grasp in principle
this is like when people ask me you know
in 50 years what is the most amazing
thing you think will happen
my favorite prediction is we'll
understand what happened at the
beginning of the universe i could be
wrong about that footnote as usual but
that's my feeling because i don't see
any obstacles
to doing it except that it's hard right
except that we don't have any direct
information because the information
about whatever happened at the very
beginning of the universe is sort of
uh
transformed over time you know rubbed
out by either inflation or the microwave
background or whatever it's hard to get
direct empirical
data but it's not
impossible to build a theory that will
be just so compelling and clear that it
will make a statement about what
happened at the beginning and everyone
go yeah it's probably true we're not
sure because we can't see it but that
seems to be the right way to go
that to me is the miracle of science uh
that you know the world obeys patterns
and we have the ability to discern these
patterns
even when these patterns are way outside
our comfort zone way outside our
everyday experience that's the power of
math and logic and philosophy and
science and so forth
tools of thinking about the nature of
reality and then it's our human
duty
to accommodate
our understanding to those very alien
terms that's why quantum mechanics is
hard because quantum mechanics talks
about the world
in a way that is fundamentally different
than our everyday experience and that's
why a hundred years later
we don't agree about what quantum
mechanics says because different human
beings have different levels of cope
when they're thinking about quantum
mechanics maybe some are too willing to
be radical some are not willing enough
we're not sure yet that's why we're
talking about it but i think we are
making progress i'm optimistic that it
will happen
michael blau says your recent episode
with andrew lee in episode 19 with tyler
cowan each bring up the question of
evaluating humanity's current decisions
in light of their impact on future
generations and so i'm editing a little
bit but that you already get the point
right you know how should we
evaluate humanity's current decisions in
light of future generations
i'm i'm not done talking about this on
the podcast i think this is a very
crucial question um i i see
strongly the arguments for two opposite
lines of reasoning one line of reasoning
is
you know basically what andrew and tyler
would both push namely
human beings in the future
are just as real
count just as much as human beings now
like you would feel bad
if you knew
that some
mild decision you made now had terrible
awful consequences for the whole future
of humanity and you would rightfully
feel bad you'd think you would you were
doing something wrong
and if you try to make that
understanding kind of rigorous
and think about what's going on you
might say look there's going to be a lot
of people in the future and tiny
decisions we make now can have enormous
leverage over what's going to happen to
them in the future therefore we should
take that into account at a very very
high level of concern i get that line of
reasoning
here's another line of reasoning we're
terrible at predicting the consequences
of our actions over the very very long
term uh there are time scales you can't
ignore the time scales in the problem
okay
um there are things we do that have
pretty clear implications on the time
scale of a year or 10 years
if you think about what people might
have said a hundred years ago
trying to make predictions for what life
would be like now
it's hard to imagine they would have
done a very good job right and if
anything the pace of change is
accelerating i think it's kind of not
hard to imagine that we're bad now at
predicting what the world will be like a
hundred years in the future and a
hundred years is nothing
we should we could imagine humanity
extending a thousand a million a billion
years into the future a billion is hard
we would evolve into something else but
you know you know what i mean there
might be something going down the line
so my point is that even if
i care a lot about those people i have
no idea how to make their lives better i
think that's the the humble realistic
reading of the situation um so it's not
that i wouldn't care about them it's
just that i'm i try to be clear-eyed
about what i can do about it
which isn't that much
whereas
the decisions i make might be have very
predictable consequences on the year or
ten year time scale so to me it makes
perfect sense to for all intents and
purposes discount
the value of lives in the future just
not because they're not important just
because i don't know what they're going
to be like and therefore i can't judge
what to do now on the basis of that kind
of analysis
ford prefect probably a pseudonym says
in one of the amas you described how big
chunk of your work comprises of among
others stretches of time dedicated to
just thinking do you ever get sad
frustrated or otherwise uneasy when you
don't seem to progress in any obvious
way during such sessions
especially for a longer period of time
have you ever felt that you've wasted
the time and so how do you deal with
that if not why do you think that's the
case
excuse me so
yeah i mean there's long periods where
progress is not only stagnant or maybe
even negative maybe you realize that
something you thought was true or you
thought that you had done succeeded in
achieving uh goes away that absolutely
happens all the time i think you're not
thinking about that mostly you're
thinking about sort of the time when
you're just mulling or just sort of
musing over what's going on
hoping for a breakthrough or whatever
those are absolutely part of
the
that's part of the deal right i mean
when i was at sfi i was joking to
someone how do you ever get work done
around here there's too many people that
are interesting to talk to and and the
answer correct answer was
that's part of the work that is that
counts you never know when that little
conversation might spark something
it's less obvious
than when you're just sitting silently
by yourself in your own office but still
your brain can be working and moving and
you can't skip that part you know and
it's weird for people who have different
kinds of jobs where you know work is a
little bit more evident a little bit
more manifest in the world you're
lifting something up or you're driving
somewhere or whatever
if you're a writer
or an artist or a scientist there's a
lot of time that is spent sitting not
doing anything and there are things
happening inside your brain but they're
not evident to the outside world
how do you deal with it when it doesn't
work um
you know
you ask the question do you ever feel
you've wasted the time
look you absolutely can waste time you
can waste time by thinking that
something is
correct and trying to build on it
or by thinking that you have a strategy
for attacking a problem that turns out
not to pay off
um
and you can waste time by playing video
games or watching tv or whatever so i'm
gonna count playing video games or
watching tv or eating a good meal as
important self-care parts of the routine
so that's not wasting time
but the thing about the intellectual
wasting time is you don't know it ahead
of time you don't know what kind of
directions are going to pay off you can
you can be a really great scientist and
just have some sixth sense about what is
going to get you in the right direction
some people seem to have a real genius
for choosing good problems and good
strategies but no one is perfect no one
gets it right all the time
so i think you know i don't have that
much
trouble living with the idea
that the
observable part of progress
is highly sporadic and non-linear and
non-predictable right you're working
your work and you're working it looks
like nothing's getting done and then you
make a breakthrough but really all that
previous work was necessary to get to
the breakthrough so even if sometimes
the time is wasted i don't know it ahead
of time so i'm not sad about doing that
i just take that as part of the job
jim murphy says do you have any cute
stories about meeting your wife or maybe
one of your first dates
uh yeah we have a really cute story
about meeting it was back in 2006
i want to say
uh yeah it was 2006. so i was living in
chicago but i was already sort of
knowing that i was going to be moving to
los angeles
jennifer was living in washington dc
as a freelance writer part-time working
for the american physical society
writing for them
and uh she had just come out with her
first book black bodies and quantum cats
it's a great book that i can recommend
you check out and uh
you know if you think back then right
2006
this was still the early days of the
modern social media landscape there was
no twitter facebook etc but there were
blogs remember blogs i still have one
occasionally contribute to it
um but the idea like just like i will i
will tell you this um
my publisher for my new book uh the
biggest ideas in the universe full of
equations did ask in a somewhat
embarrassed tone of voice
are you on tick-tock
the kids today like tik-tok and they
were wondering whether or not there's
anything i can do on tick tock
to advertise this book um that's what
you would get today and the answer is no
i'm not really on tick tock and i don't
think that it would help with this book
we'll see maybe i'll have a genius idea
but at the time in 2006 if you wrote a
new book especially as a brand new
author you'd be told to start a blog so
jennifer started a blog that was
cocktail party physics i think the
website still exists and you can check
out all the old blog posts
um
and again back then there weren't that
many blogs so especially physics blogs
in particular there was a very small
number of them you know single digits
maybe use double digits by then but it
was not a large number
so uh we were a tight-knit group and i
emailed her saying um welcome to the
blogosphere you know here's some other
blogs to check out some tips etc etc and
we emailed back and forth and realized
we were going to
be at the same physics conference in a
couple weeks we arranged to meet up and
that was that
now we're married
i'm going to skip some details in
between but that is how we met through
our blogs through reading each other's
blogs and when we did get married our uh
marriage was announced in nature there
was a little
blurb in the beginning of the pages of
nature saying you know two physics
bloggers get married that's cute right i
think it's cute
i have different opinions about what is
cute than other people
cooper says
do you agree with the idea that if we
find life on europa or in settle
enceladus i always say in settlers but
it's enceladus then bayesian reasoning
could would conclude that life is highly
likely to be found in most star systems
uh not precisely cooper you know better
than that because
bayesian reasoning has two parts it has
priors and it has likelihood functions
and when you get new data
like there's life on europa or enceladus
then you use the likelihood function
what is the probability that life would
exist on europa if life were everywhere
versus if life were nowhere
and then you multiply it by the prior
right so
surely if you find life on somewhere in
the solar system the likelihood of
finding that is way bigger
in a world where life is ubiquitous than
in a world where life is rare or i
should say a universe or a galaxy where
life is rare
so absolutely your credence that life
should be frequent in the universe
should go up
substantially
but
what was it before what was it before
you had that measurement if you had a
prior
that the probability that life was
ubiquitous in the universe is 10 to the
minus 100 then finding life on europa is
not going to change that by that much
now i don't have a prior that is nearly
that tiny so in practice i think that
finding life on europa or enceladus does
give us very good reason to believe that
life is maybe not most star systems but
life is frequent in the star systems
that have reasonable kind of planets um
that would be given my priors that would
be my conclusion but i can't blame just
bayesian reasoning on that or give
credit to bayesian reasoning i have to
tell you what my priors are to draw that
conclusion
john shoning also asks a bayesian
question to be a good informal bayesian
in life is it possible to replace
choosing a prior
with another bayesian sub problem
pushing the choice of prior further up
the stack until you reach a point closer
to the edge of the system
um i mean roughly i think no is the
right answer you can sort of trick
yourself into thinking that you can fake
it
but really you know when people talk
about priors they talk about your
current credences that's really what you
mean i mean what is a prior you're not
the born you're not you're well you're
not conceived you're a little fetus
having credences for different
propositions about factual statements
about the world right you develop them
over time um but we're not really
talking about development in time we're
talking about intellectual development
but the point is
priors are starting points they're not
finishing points you can argue for them
but when you're arguing for them really
what you're doing is relating
one prior to another you're saying is
that really is the prior you claim
so let's say i say i have a prior that
life in the galaxy is very very very
rare
but i also claim i have a prior that the
chemistry on different planets is all
the same as the chemistry in the solar
system and there are a huge number of
planets and that you know given the
chemistry of life on a planet it's
pretty easy to make life
that's an inconsistent set of priors and
therefore i can change my priors because
i'm not being internally coherent but
i'm just at some point allowed to pick
whatever i want i think that the goal of
justifying priors in some absolute
foundational sense is not the right goal
to have you know we human beings are not
disembodied logical reasoners we're part
of the world
we have pictures of what makes sense to
us and what doesn't make sense to us and
that's where we get our priors from and
that's okay that's not a mistake that's
not a bug it's a feature of how the
system works
russ dill says in your podcast with
michael dine there was a brief
discussion of ruling out physics that
predicts the universe would decay to a
lower energy state with some reasonable
probability
is vacuum decay actually a problem with
respect to the many world's
interpretation wouldn't we just be able
to ignore any branches of the wave
function where vacuum decay occurs
so long as there's a non-zero
probability that branches still exist
where it has not occurred so this is
just i mean maybe you know this russ but
this is just a quantum suicide
experiment right you're asking yourself
if i have some quantum event which is
set up in such a way that on one branch
of the wave function i instantly die
painlessly
not knowing even what happened on the
other branch of the function i continue
to live that is literally an
implementation of this vacuum decay
scenario and there's an argument that
says look on the branches where you
don't exist you don't care
you have no feelings you're not sad
you're gone
the only caring that is involved with
you is on the branches where you exist
and therefore why is this bad why should
you feel bad about this but
you kind of should be suspicious about
these words from the start because
already you've made a huge classic
mistake
in many worlds analysis you're talking
about you
as if you exist on more than one branch
at once you're saying there's the u on
this branch the u on the other branch
those are separate people
it's not that there's a you that exists
in you that doesn't exist so there's a
person who has lived and a person who
has died
okay those persons are both
sharing a past you
that is a feature of that is different
in everyday in logic than in the usual
single world way of thinking about the
world but they're different people
they're like identical twins okay no one
ever says it's okay if i killed this one
identical twin because they stole the
other identical twin is living they're
different people
it's exactly the same for
these kind of quantum suicide vacuum
decay experiments the point is that
right now
i have value in continuing to exist
i would be sad now if i thought that i
was going to die
in a minute even if that death was
completely
painless and even if
after death i didn't feel anything i'm
i'm sad now about that future prospect
and my claim is
you should be sad in exactly the same
way
if your quantum descendants on all the
different branches of the wave function
are going to die
exactly that amount of sadness maybe not
the same sadness as if all of them are
going to die but there's still some
sadness there so i think it does matter
i don't think you just ignore the
branches on which you don't exist any
more than you ignore a future in which
you don't exist
which after all if you go far enough in
the future is all the futures you will
not exist in them
josh bauer asks on what basis does one
choose a meta-ethical framework
in the vein of can't get a knot from an
is logic is out and it seems like the
only foundation comes down to personal
preference but if that's the case why do
philosophers debate moral frameworks is
it my preferences better than your
preference not just begging the question
of what better means sorry is my
preference is better than your
preference not just begging the question
of what better means and is there any
hope of finding a framework that can be
agreed upon across culture if it's all
down to preference
so i think that again
my analysis of how you should build a
moral framework is more or less what
people actually do
the statement is the there's no claim
that is very effectual to the point of
saying my preference is better than your
preference without as you say knowing
what better means but you can say here's
what my preference is and there's two
things two places to go from there one
is as as we said earlier
preferences are often not internally
coherent okay so there's the whole
process of taking a list of preferences
each of which seems perfectly plausible
and systematizing them and saying okay
what is the general principle from which
these preferences might grow that's how
you get things like utilitarianism or
deontology or virtue ethics it depends
on what your preferences are you can
actually land on an ethical system that
says my preference is the most happiness
for the most people and then you try to
say look what does that mean right what
is it what does happiness mean how do i
add it up how do i make it the most what
kind of people count all those
complicated questions come out of that
and then the other aspect is
you talk to people you realize you're
not the only person in the world
maybe other people's preferences are
different and there's two things one is
that you can shape each other's
preferences
you can give a sales pitch saying look
if you think that that's important you
should also think this is important
right
that actually happens in the world that
is not some weird mistake that is how
things work and the other thing is you
can disagree
there could be people who will just
fundamentally disagree
and this dream of imagining the correct
moral framework in which everyone agrees
that it's right and and obeys it is
entirely implausible in my point of view
that's why i think it's very important
to have political social structures that
allow for disagreement where people can
accept that they disagree on some things
agree to agree on other things and on
the basis of what they agree on build a
society in which they can work with
people in which they disagree about some
things
sometimes the disagreements will be so
large that you can't live with them and
that's when you throw them in jail or go
to war or run away or whatever it is you
have to do again as you see from all the
examples
these are all things that really do
happen in the world it's not just some
hopeless mess it's how life is lived and
what i'm really advocating is not a
change in how life is lived but an
acknowledgement and that that's how life
is lived rather than
inventing false goals of having perfect
agreement perfect foundational
establishment of the moral
rules or whatever you might hope to get
oleg ravinsky says if you had to pick a
philosopher living or otherwise to have
a long conversation with who would that
be and why
so
i i'm not sure what to say about this so
the answer is i don't know that's the
short answer i don't know i don't have
an answer to this the reason why i chose
to answer the question i'm trying to do
this without dismissing the question but
i want to indicate that this is not my
kind of question to which i have good
answers okay and maybe it's interesting
why i don't have good answers to this
question
um i
and the cheap and easy way to say it is
that i don't like heroes i don't like
hero worship and i know that you didn't
mention here i'm not trying to pick on
you here oleg um but the kind of
idea that there are great people
great men great women whatever uh who
you would really like to talk to that
would change your life i just don't like
that whole idea
i like ideas right and i i think that of
the people i've known there have been
really good ideas that a lot of
different people have had
now of course some people seem to be
better at having good ideas than others
there is no rule that says that all
people are equally interesting or good
to talk to
but the point is i just don't
conceptualize what i want to do as i
would love to talk to this person
that's just not my goal in life i would
love to talk about these ideas with
people who are interested in it and have
interesting things to say about it and
that'll be different for all sorts of
ideas
so i'm sort of wimping out of answering
the question but i'm trying to explain
why i'm wimping out there's i just don't
have a list of people who i really like
to talk to you know
i'm reminded of uh the story which might
be completely
um
anecdotal or even completely fake but
you know apparently marcel proust
the great french writer and james joyce
the great irish writer once shared a cab
where they shared a ride anyway and
there was someone else in the in the cab
and you know they were the other person
the onlooker was asked like what did
they talk about the great minds
and the answer was yeah they were silent
the whole ride they didn't have anything
to say to each other
just because a person has great ideas
or is you know accomplished or moral or
whatever doesn't mean they're a great
person to talk to always and vice versa
there can be charming conversationalists
who you know are not necessarily going
to be building the next great scientific
theory or technological advance so
i'm just a pluralist about ideas and
experiences and people and all those
things
and i know that even some of the
smartest and best people in the world
have their flaws
so i again i don't i'm not so silly as
to think that i want to talk to every
person equally
but i don't have a list of top five that
i would really just be dying to talk to
sorry
g cloon says i watched a video with you
on the institute of art and ideas player
in a discussion with roger penrose where
you said there are people in our past
who think we are in their past the time
runs in the opposite direction for them
as it does for us
could you elaborate more on that idea
it's very difficult to wrap one's head
around this concept
i'm not going to say too much about it
because i think that some people
here listening i've heard me talk about
it a lot
but it's the whole subject of my book
from eternity to here if you want to dig
that far into it the crucial thing is
the two two crucial things one is that
i think that the arrow of time
which defines the difference between
past and future is entirely down to
entropy increasing over time entropy
used to be lower in the past will be
higher in the future okay
and within our observable universe
entropy has just been increasing so
everyone in our observable universe
agrees on the same direction of time
the second thing is there could be more
to life than the observable universe and
so this is an outgrowth of
a model that i proposed with jennifer
chen back in 2004
a cosmology model where there are baby
universes
so there's individual small pockets of
universe small compared to the whole
thing they're still very very big
uh pockets of universe that have a low
entropy end and a high entropy end
and the collection of all of these
uh takes the form of
there's a moment of time
where the entropy is as low as it ever
gets
it doesn't mean it's low that's the
great thing about our model it doesn't
mean it's low it's just lower than it is
at other times okay it's a relative
measure and on one side of time you have
these baby universes being created with
low entropy and then increasing in
entropy
away from that middle moment and on the
other side of time you also have baby
universes being created with low entropy
and growing with entropy in the
direction away from that middle moment
so there's a crossover moment
in which
the arrow time goes away from it in both
directions so therefore oppositely
oriented
um on different sides of that moment if
you hear noises in the background i have
a big box
that caliban just jumped into so there's
a kitty running around the box i think
it's calibrated let me check
oh
i was wrong it's ariel she's jumping
around in the box caliban is more the
box jumper but two kitties you never
know
anyway i hope that uh explained that um
you know the point is the thing that
saves you from any conceptual worries
here is that the people for whom we are
in their past are not only really really
really really far in our past but so far
there's no connection there's no
communication there's no um way of
talking to them that would get you in
trouble okay
franklin marek says i would love to know
how your thoughts on the cosmic
censorship hypothesis
i would love to know your thoughts on
the cosmic censorship and hypothesis and
naked singularities do you think there
is a way to get a black hole super
extremal
you know roughly speaking no so the
cosmic center censorship hypothesis
which goes back to former mindscape
guest roger penrose although he invented
it long before he was on the podcast
basically says that there are
singularities in nature but they're
hidden behind event horizons that's what
we think is true for ordinary black
holes right
and as far as we know from numerical
simulations and analytic investigations
of general relativity
this is almost true but not quite
so you can actually show there was great
work done by matthew choptewick for
example
that if you
pick your initial conditions with
infinitely precise
specification of where you start you can
get a naked singularity strictly
speaking by the rules of the game
the cosmic censorship conjecture is not
true and so i think i'm not gonna
remember the details of this but you
know kip thorne has a bunch of bets with
stephen hawking and other people and i
think that one of their bets was about
cosmic censorship and i think that i
forget who and who's on what side but
they conceded the bet anyway because of
this work by choptwick i think hawking
conceded the bad i think he was wrong
about this one
but but i kind of am not that
invested in this particular result
because i don't think the classical
gender relativity is the right theory of
the world right the world is quantum
mechanical and i think there's a whole
way of thinking about classical general
relativity that
pretends that classical general
relativity is right and takes it to its
extremes and asks what happens in these
incredibly dramatic situations whereas i
think that in nature
once you get to these incredibly
dramatic situations classical general
relativity isn't going to be right in a
big way so the very vocabulary we use to
talk about it singularities horizons
this is just not going to make sense not
going to really apply that's my actual
feeling about cosmic censorship
bits plus atoms says brian greene
tweeted when you cross over to the edge
of a black hole space and time
interchange their roles you are drawn
toward the black hole center with the
same inevitability as you are drawn to
the next moment in time others have
given similar descriptions
since space doesn't have an arrow now
this is the question
and space is taking on the role of time
what accounts for the arrow of time in
this case is it still increasing entropy
okay so i have to um
you know i have to shatter a few idols
here you know brian is a good friend of
mine brian green and he was a former
mindscape guest and his statement in
that tweet is entirely wrong
it's just not true that space and time
interchange their roles i know exactly
why he would say that
there are coordinates that we put on
space-time and we put them on space-time
for good reasons having to do with the
symmetries that exist in space time et
cetera et cetera
and in the usual coordinate system
that we use outside a black hole
you have a radial coordinate that tells
you how far away you are from the black
hole and of course you have a time
coordinate as well as angular
coordinates
and
the role of the radial coordinate and
the time coordinate
switch inside the event horizon okay so
what that means is the coordinate r
the distance from the black hole the
radial distance the distance in the
straight line from the center
is what we call a space-like coordinate
outside the event horizon you move along
r you change your position in space not
in time whereas the t-coordinate the
time coordinate is a time coordinate
those same coordinates exist and can be
discussed inside the black hole by the
way
i have a book coming out that explains
this in great detail this is all
explained in the biggest ideas
inside the event horizon the
r-coordinate moves in a time-like
direction and the t-coordinate moves in
a space-like direction so that's why
people say
space and time interchange their roles
but they didn't
what changed their roles was space and
time coordinates but who cares
coordinates are made up by human beings
they're not out there written
in space time you don't bump into r and
t those are just a way that you use to
describe it you could and very often do
use better coordinates in which case
it's not true that they switch their uh
identities at all so
what follows from that is that the
following statement you are drawn toward
the black hole center with the same
inevitability as you're drawn to the
next moment in time
not also i mean that's closer to being
accurate but still not accurate because
what you're drawn to is r equals zero
the radial coordinate equals zero that's
where the singularity is but the point
is it's not the center
of the black hole it's just not it's a
moment in the future
we know what a center is it's a location
in space at the middle of some spheres
right that is not what r equals zero is
it's not a location in space it is a
moment in time because now r is a
time-like coordinate so
the point of the tweet is correct
the point is once you are inside the
black hole you are drawn toward the
singularity with the same inevitability
as you move toward the future but the
words in which it's particularly
expressed there i just completely
disagree with as a correct way to think
about what general relativity is really
saying and so for the arrow of time time
is just time it doesn't matter what
coordinates you use and yes it is still
due to increasing entropy
alex b says if you were placed in the
plot of a scary ghost movie how long
would you make it before updating your
prior to ghosts being real this is an
excellent question i know that it sounds
like a silly question but i think it's a
really important question if you want to
be a
fair um legitimate rigorously thinking
bayesian naturalist who doesn't believe
in ghosts you have to say okay what is
the evidence that would take uh for me
to before i started believing in ghosts
and you know it would be pretty far
let's put it this way
i think it'd be pretty far now compared
to what it would have been a thousand
years ago
both because our knowledge of the
physical world was not as good back then
and therefore was much more reasonable
to believe in ghosts but also because
we have experience now
with magicians
with illusionists with fakers right and
so we know that there's a lot of data a
lot of experiences a lot of things you
could notice
um that might
naively point you in the direction of
believing in ghosts that could be easily
faked and you have to take you have to
take that into consideration you have to
admit that that's a possibility when
you're doing these kinds of calculations
um
so but the thing is if ghost really
existed it wouldn't be subtle it
wouldn't be hard to notice it wouldn't
be like you heard a bang in a room you
thought was empty or you saw a smudgy
reflection in the mirror or something
like that you know girls could just come
up and say hi
right why not i mean if they really
existed i think this is a more logical
argument in the case of god existing
than ghosts because i don't know what
the rules about ghosts are
but somewhere along those lines you know
almost no collection of
bangs in the night and things falling
over and smudges in the mirror or in
photographs would make me change my
priors very much but some very
noticeable manifestation of someone who
i knew to be dead
uh who could give a convincing
description of who who they were and
what they knew and answer some questions
about the afterlife etc i would be
willing to change my priors i don't know
exactly how quickly he would take but i
would get there i promise
jimmy summer says
there seems to be two irreconcilable
views of progress that both posit a
fundamental difference in how we create
knowledge and how it grows in one view
the differences between our theories of
physics in say a thousand years and five
thousand years should be relatively
similar
assuming of course we continue to make
steady progress
on the other view our theories of
physics in a thousand years and five
thousand years will be radically
incomprehensibly different because the
growth of knowledge has no cut off even
in any specific field which of these two
views are you partial to and why
um
not completely sure i understand the two
different scenarios but i think i have a
vague idea and the short answer is i
don't know you know i think that it's
important
to stress two things and these are two
things that i think are just obviously
perfectly
unmistakably true yet people like to
emphasize one and forget about the other
one thing is we don't know
what's going to happen in the future as
far as scientific knowledge is concerned
we've lived through a series of
revolutions in science that have
completely changed our point of view of
the world
and so it's completely allowed to
imagine
that revolutions will continue and like
you say things are going to be
completely different in the future like
there's no way
that you can principally argue
sorry are you in a principled way that
that's impossible okay that there can't
be huge revolutions coming the other
thing that is true is as i said before
we know a lot more about the fundamental
nature of reality now than we did 500
years ago
maybe we're close to being done
that is absolutely a
possibility scientific progress doesn't
have momentum
it's not like well we've had a bunch of
revolutions in the last 500 years
therefore ergo we will have a bunch of
revolutions in the next thousand years
or the next 500. we we don't know it's
possible you're literally asking a
question about something that is
precisely what's impossible to know
because if we knew the answer to that
we'd be much closer just doing it today
rather than a thousand years from now if
i don't know what the revolution is
gonna be
i can't tell you how likely it is it's
going to happen right
so i'm kind of wishy-washy on this one i
think we should just absolutely keep an
open mind i know a lot of people like to
you know
argue on the basis of history or logic
or whatever that either things are
almost done or they're nowhere near done
i have no idea and of course this is
something where i am always
misunderstood because i make the point
that the laws of physics underlying
everyday life are completely known in
terms of the core theory people because
people
have short attention spans and have
difficulty having ideas stick in their
minds they think i'm saying we're close
to understanding everything which is
explicitly what i'm not saying and i try
very hard to make the difference clear
people don't want to hear the difference
so that's why i'm completely happy to
say i have no idea whether or not we
will have revolutions in our fundamental
understanding of reality but a thousand
or five thousand years from now there
will still be atoms we will still
believe in the electromagnetic force and
in electrons and protons and neutrons
evolving according to the core theory
nick g says what's your take on gerard
tuft and suskin's holographic principle
as a solution to the information paradox
i just read suskin's black hole wars and
wondering if there's any dissenting
opinion among physicists
well i mean i think it's a crucially
important insight you know maybe not
everyone agrees but i think that the
standard view among working theoretical
physicists these days is that holography
the idea that what's happening in black
hole can be represented by information
spread across the boundary of the black
hole across the event horizon uh is both
true and important i think that's the
consensus it's not maybe consensus is
too strong i think that's the most
common view okay there's absolutely some
dissent there always is dissent
physicists love them they love the
dissent and i love them for it
it's not
by itself a solution to the information
paradox
there had been over the last let's say
five years
a couple of times when people have
claimed to have solutions to the
information paradox and i think that
some of them represent genuine
progress genuine you know new ways of
thinking that might very well be helpful
here on the podcast we talked to ned
englehart who's one of the leaders in
this field and she and her colleagues
have have done absolutely important work
that sheds light on how information
might come out of black holes but as she
said as i said
we're not done yet it's not the solution
we're not there okay
um so i think it's an important step
along the way it's insight
and it's not the final answer that would
be my opinion
derek bain says now you'll be coming to
hopkins moving to baltimore will there
be lots of speaking events and the like
open to the public hear that other
philosophically inclined baltimoreans
with an amateur's interest in physics
will be able to attend
uh i suspect yes i suspect that's the
answer you know there are i mean
johns hopkins has a pretty vibrant
community interest in interested in
science and communication and outreach
okay um that you know it says science
science is a big
part of the university science
engineering medicine as i said but
there's also humanities departments and
writing departments etc humanities
institutes there's a lot of
social science things going on so it is
a very rich
source of things like that so i cannot
say exactly what they will be but i
predict that they will exist there you
go
next table veda says
do you have any advice for aspiring
students of physics i feel that
self-doubt can become a hindrance on
one's ability to learn the material
especially if the foundations of math
aren't there to support them do you have
any habits while you were an
undergraduate that helped you focus on
your goal
these are again really important
questions to which my own ability to
give advice is very limited i think uh
in part because
it's one thing to do it you know i made
it through graduate school became a
professor etc it's a completely
different thing to be able to say what
you did
there's plenty of people who are good at
basketball who couldn't coach basketball
to save their lives
um
and so i don't know whether or not i
could articulate what was important
along the way some things that i didn't
some things i didn't and the other
reason is because everyone's different
right so the things that work for me
might not work for you
i don't think that self-doubt was one of
my biggest obstacles i had obstacles
um
in fact if anything my obstacle was i
used to think oh everything will be fine
and that was my obstacle maybe i should
have had a little bit more self-doubt
uh but it's not but that's not the right
way to spin it the right way to spin it
is not doubt versus confidence but
i do think that it's crucially important
to constantly be
aware
of what you're doing and why you're
doing it right
um it can be easy you know academia for
better for worse you know think about
academia versus becoming a musician
right yeah there's there's similarities
there's many more people who want to be
professional musicians than can be just
like there are many more people who want
to be professors who can be there's a
lot of knowledge and work you need to do
there's a good amount of luck you need
to succeed along the way
but
academia has a more or less structured
way of doing that success right you go
to undergraduate you go to graduate
school post-doc junior faculty senior
faculty whereas being a musician you can
toil away for years and then be an
overnight success many overnight
successes toiled for years and years to
get there but it's much less predictable
it's much harder to know what the next
step should be in order to succeed in
academia
you very often know what sort of you're
expected to do next expected to write a
phd thesis defend it get a postdoc write
papers the expectations are pretty clear
and actually
that can stifle creativity a little bit
right you can have your
mind focus on that next step
to the detriment of thinking about the
longer term am i working on the right
projects am i in the right place how
should i
maximize my opportunities going forward
when i take the next step etc so that
was my flaw that i was too focused on
the next year not on the next 20 years
um rather than and again i thought i
would continually think that
it'll be fine i mean you know if i'm
blaming myself for not getting tenure at
chicago it's because i thought look i'm
doing great
i'm writing all these papers they're
cited i've had a lot of students the
idea that they would not give me tenure
like literally never occurred to me as a
serious thing to worry about i had
plenty of friends who were assistant
professors at the time who were just
fretting about getting tenure and i just
didn't i'm like they'll recognize that
that i should tenure and i was totally
wrong because i was not very smart um
but of course that's not you know
there's
absolute reality to the worry about um
self-doubt right there are other people
i've known people who are brilliant who
are great at doing science and who
didn't seem to know it themselves uh
students of my own who i've had to say
oh no you'll be great like i i i worry
that i don't say that enough to my
students because to me it's obvious
they're great the ones who are great
most of them maybe all of them um but
maybe they don't say it enough because
to me it's obvious and and i have a
standard for comparison that they don't
so
sorry i don't have good advice
for dealing with the self-doubt other
than um
you know
i i i tend to think that self-doubt
itself is not the target
right like in other words if you're if
you're trying to say how do i deal with
self-doubt
the cheap answer which is which i
suspect has some correctness to it is
do awesome things and then your
self-doubt will go away right you know
be you know really put whatever
abilities you have into
succeeding you know like again i've
known a lot of people
graduate student level who thought like
if only they could be introduced to the
famous professors at conferences then
they would be fine
i have to tell them like it doesn't do
any good to be introduced to the famous
professors if they say so what are you
working on what do you do and you don't
have a good answer
you got to have the stuff you got to
have the accomplishments and those
accomplishments might be you know
passing your qualifying exams or getting
a good grade or even just coming to
understand something difficult in
physics um but that's got to be your
focus and i i tend to think that the
other things will come along with it not
painlessly not without work
but once you keep doing good things
you'll eventually say huh yeah maybe i
can do this maybe i'm pretty good at
this after all it's doing the good
things that has to come first
bruno texera says i really like the
podcast with dr sherry turkle you asked
her something about chat bots to keep
company keep people company and her
answer was something like totally wrong
that's a job for people
i get her point but i would like to i
would like your take on my more
utilitarian view why not both people
will continue to be selfish sons and
grandsons will continue to forget about
their elderly etc while we struggle to
make the world more humane can't we in
parallel try to help people in some
other less than perfect way
so
i
am inclined to be on your side bruno in
this point like why not both right like
if there is a chat bot that helps
someone feel wanted or loved or whatever
uh
why not if the alternative is not having
that and they don't feel loved that
doesn't from a utilitarian perspective
if you want to be utilitarian about this
that doesn't seem like the way to go
let me just put and i'm not going to
conclude with any definitive statement
here but let me put two other thoughts
into your mind one is
it can certainly be easy to say
oh we're just helping a little bit it's
better than the alternative
and use that as an excuse to not do
something really better right to to say
well you know we can't do everything
perfectly so we'll give them a chatbot
we can't give them a real human being
who cares about them so they can talk to
the computer and kind of use that either
explicitly or
implicitly as a reason not to do
something more meaningful with a real
human being that loves them in some way
okay so i think as a practical matter
you cannot get around the the idea that
that's a possible failure mode in that
particular way of thinking
and the other aspect is
even if it
works in some sense to
let uh you know an elderly person or you
know someone who doesn't have a lot of
friends or whatever it is to feel human
connection by talking to a chatbot
i think that sherry's point is it's not
human connection it's just not right
it's fake
and so even if again in a utilitarian
way you're giving them some momentary
pleasure you're not giving them what
they think
they need to get that pleasure it's kind
of fake pleasure
this is not a perfect analogy but you
know imagine the classic science fiction
example of a happiness drug we have we
have drugs that are pretty close to that
right there's a drug you can take yours
happy all the time
if you thought that the goal of life was
to be happy all the time maybe just take
that drug and sit in your chair and
waste away and die but you're happy all
the time right
there's something in that
that is unsatisfying to us even if we
started by agreeing that we just want to
be happy all the time there's something
that is not genuine about it
and so i think an argument can be made
and again i don't know how far to push
the argument
but i think an argument can be made
that
even if a chatbot does a really good job
of cheering someone up
it's not a replacement for an equally
good job and a precisely equally good
job done by a real person there's
something genuine about it and again i
would love to articulate that in a more
complete way but i'm just going to put
the idea into your head that maybe that
is something to take seriously in this
discussion
preston justice says you've done a
wonderful job explaining the schrodinger
equation
i particularly enjoyed the socratic
dialogue in chapter 8 of something
deeply hidden
well by the way thank you for saying
that preston is interesting the dialogue
in chapter eight was an experiment
and my publisher was willing to let me
do it but was a little bit skeptical and
i think that some people loved it and
some people hated it which is more or
less i guess what i should have expected
but i'm thankful to the people who loved
it
um because of your well-articulated
explanations i'm about 70 20 on the side
of many worlds interpretation
and you say i'm a good bayesian but i
think a good bayesian should have
credences that add up to 100 and maybe
you mean 70 30.
i fear i can't truly take sides or
understand the theories to the greatest
extent possible without the math and
when i look at the equation i'm
completely lost could you briefly
outline the steps for understanding the
equation mathematically the prerequisite
courses and how much can someone really
understand these theories such as many
worlds without the math you know i think
you can understand them without the math
but
it's not
there's two things happen when you don't
have the math one is you're not going to
understand it as well
i do think you can get the point
but
because you're learning it through words
and analogies and things like that the
sort of
penumbra of the point is harder to get
right all the implications of the point
are harder to get if you knew the math
then you could figure out what the
implications of them are but as long as
things are in words they're going to be
fuzzy and therefore the further you go
away from what you really and truly know
the less confident you're going to be so
that is a problem um
i forget whether i just said there are
two things i want to say but let me just
say that for the for the moment but i do
think you can understand things uh at a
pretty good level if there's but you're
gonna understand points rather than the
whole landscape if you know what i mean
um
second thing is that uh i am writing a
book
so the book that is coming out in
september the biggest ideas in the
universe is just the classical stuff
okay so hamiltonian mechanics in there
black holes are in there general
relativity but no quantum stuff that
will be the second volume which will
hopefully come out next year
but we did do the videos you can check
out my videos where i
do the math
starting from not doing the math right
it's for people who don't know the math
ahead of time
it's hard it's hard to follow without
knowing the math ahead of time but i try
to teach you calculus and complex
numbers and things like that up to the
schrodinger equation you don't get very
far into the schrodinger equation
solving it and things like that because
that requires more time but the videos
are there if you're interested
um
for your actual question briefly
outlining the steps
uh
well you need
calculus all the calculus you can get so
integrals and derivatives are what are
important in calculus for
quantum mechanics there's two other
things and sorry integrals and
derivatives but also differential
equations that's crucially important so
an equation that does not just say the
derivative equals a number but
derivatives of some functions are equal
to other functions of other things and
other derivatives and that's the whole
field of differential equations
crucially important to understanding
quantum mechanics then two other things
crucial for quantum mechanics one is
complex numbers complex variables the
wave function itself is complex there
you go and the second thing is linear
algebra which is the theory of matrices
and diagonalizing them and finding
eigenvalues
all over the place i mean literally the
name of schrodinger's paper where he
invented the schrodinger equation is
quantum mechanics as an eigenvalue
problem the word eigenvalue appears in
linear algebra the theory of matrices
okay and heisenberg's version of quantum
mechanics was
matrix mechanics you need to know
matrices and you can learn all those
things those are all things that
typical math or physics students learn
their first or second year of undergrad
so
it's not like it's very very very far
away if you want to dive in
justin wolcott says priority question
how can libertarian free will exist if
all events including the thoughts and
actions of gods are either deterministic
or random
that's an easy one they can't
in that case
libertarian free will the word
libertarian is very important here it
means that
it is not
reducible to the laws of physics so
somehow agents have to violate the laws
of physics so there are not laws either
deterministic or random
that tell you what's going to happen
that's it i don't believe in libertarian
free will i'm a compatibilist about
determinism and free will so i believe
in both deterministic laws and
free will at the level of an emerging
higher level description
jeff b says last ama you mentioned
something about different branches of
the wave function potentially having
different laws of physics
if that's the case is there a mechanism
by which the branches could develop new
laws what were the original laws at the
big bang
so we don't know i mean this is all
speculative stuff like okay the short
answer is that we don't know i'm
actually thinking about it though
you know
quantum mechanics cosmology these are
things that don't go well together but
we can sort of speculate on the basis of
we know a lot about individually quantum
mechanics and cosmology
so one thing you know i wrote a paper
last year with jackie lodman who was an
undergraduate at caltech on energy
non-conservation in quantum mechanics
the idea being that a measurement could
change the average energy of the branch
of the wave function you're on and i
think that people will debate about the
words
the meaning of the word energy and
whatever but i think the physics that we
described in that paper is rock solid
it's it's it's baby quantum mechanics
it's there's not a lot there to disagree
with
um but what it implies
from the many worlds perspective
is that if you can think about
the wave function of the universe as a
superposition of different kinds of
states right that's what quantum
mechanics says
and what happens as time goes on is that
you narrow down
what
parts of the wave function are
contributing to the superposition you're
on that's why the energy can change
because you're not participating in all
of the previous states you're sort of
well there were a lot of possibilities
added together but now i picked out one
okay
i think it's true and this is far from
established but i think it's true that
that can appear as changing the laws
changing the laws that apply on your
specific branch of the wave function so
to answer your question the original
laws are whatever laws govern the whole
collection of all the branches of the
wave function of the universe
and the ones that you observe on any one
branch might be a subset and therefore
look different
than that so it's not really that the
branches are developing new laws is that
the apparent laws you observe seem to be
changing with time because you're sort
of participating in less and less of the
wave function of the universe again
speculative stuff we don't know if
that's what actually happens
dragon sided
says many of us are still reeling at the
loss of friends co-workers family
members to what we now understand to be
intentional disinformation campaigns
otherwise fairly normal seemingly
reasonable people have firm beliefs in
all matter of easily falsifiable
theories about diseases political events
and so forth
over the past two years have you
observed this in any people in your
social or professional circle
and can you offer any thoughts about
ways that civil society can overcome the
pandemic of disinformation
well it's a crucially important question
and my thoughts are not very
strong on this and in part there's not
very strong because i appreciate the
difficulty
of the social science question that is
being asked here
um
research in these areas are hard and
it's easy as teen wen would uh remind us
it's easy to fake yourself into clarity
to go oh this is the reason why people
are so susceptible to this information
and then the data turned out not to bear
that out but you stick with your
previous opinion we're all susceptible
to disinformation depending on our
pre-existing prejudices
so i don't like to be very definitive
about how to combat these things um
i have people in my like family friend
circle
who have been susceptible to this but
not really my like close friends or
professional circles
no one in the caltech physics department
is uh falling prey to these
conspiracy theories and disinformation
that much or at least i haven't noticed
of course we've also been in pandemic so
maybe i haven't talked to them enough
maybe i don't know
um
how can civil society overcome it
you know
there's there's two things there's sort
of like the blunt thing and then there's
the more subtle systematic thing the
blunt thing is
we have to be uh good role models we
have to give good information
you know it's it's kind of easy and fun
to point out people being dumb but
that's not actually very constructive it
doesn't convince them to be right
even when people are in the grips of
some terrible disinformation conspiracy
theory you still got to treat them like
a person and make them want to change
their minds you don't make them want to
change their minds by berating them and
telling them that they're stupid you
have to give them an off ramp you have
to explain well does this thing that
you're saying really compatible with
this thing have you ever thought of the
possibility that something else is going
on they have to make the journey
themselves and you can guide them and
help them
but you can't just you know say oh
you're an idiot
please believe me instead that that will
never work
the other thing the more
systematic thing is you know ask why
they believe it in the first place
why would some people fall for these
things like let's get take an extreme
example as a basketball fan i'm well
aware that kyrie irving who's one of the
best basketball players on the planet is
also a conspiracy theorist a literal
flat earth conspiracy theorist didn't
take the vaccine for covet etc um
many people have made fun of him okay i
don't need to add to that
so instead
let's ask why would any you know someone
who has all the resources in the world
why in the world
would they believe in the flat earth
conspiracy theory
right i mean ask it in a sincere way
don't ask it just in an eye-rolling way
like why in the world would that happen
like
no really
why would someone believe that look it's
not because they actually
have been thinking about all the
possible scientific evidence and
said okay in my you know considered
opinion i think the scientific evidence
is better explained by flat earth that's
not why there are other reasons why
one big factor is
maybe the people in the establishment
have been telling them that the earth is
round not flat
and the people in the establishment have
been telling them a lot of other false
[ __ ] at the same time maybe that is
what they believe maybe they are
built to be skeptical of received wisdom
and maybe that's not completely crazy
right maybe they have been lied to or
maybe they've been misled or
discriminated against or whatever
try to open yourself up to the mental
space that these other people have and
ask okay like
why would anyone feel that way
why would they feel like they've been
lied to is it because they've been lied
to
is it uh i mean by the good people as
well as the bad people the people we
would call good and bad
and ideally this is just impossible
in practice but the sort of ideal state
would be one in which
people in our society didn't feel that
way and it's because all people in our
society were respected and successful
right i think if we lived in a society
where people were educated and not
discriminated against and were told the
truth by the establishment etc etc
susceptibility to crazy conspiracy
theories would be a lot less it's much
harder to achieve that kind of uh
systematic societal change in any easy
way but i think that's where i would
ultimately want to go
the shannon klein says are there
questions other than conditions in the
singularity the beginning of the cosmos
or conditions inside a black hole that
require a theory of quantum gravity
well it depends what you mean by require
again what questions do you want to ask
okay look my favorite example is the sun
the sun in the sky depending if it's
daytime or night time where you are if
there are clouds but you know what the
sun is right
well what is it what do you mean you
know what the sun is what is the sun
well you say it's a collection of
plasma you know protons and helium and
things like that well okay what are
those things what do they do
well one thing is they are a source of
gravity
right the sun creates a gravitational
field it warps the space time around it
affects the evolution of the earth's
orbit right we can all agree on that
that is described in our best scientific
understanding by general relativity the
theory of gravity that einstein gave us
there's another thing the sun does for
us it gives us energy light coming from
the sun how does that happen
well through nuclear fusion ultimately
fusion of protons by various cycles into
heavier elements
which is a completely quantum mechanical
process
you cannot describe nuclear fusion
without quantum mechanics
so to understand what the sun is
you need to describe it simultaneously
using the language of general relativity
and quantum mechanics but we can't
we can't do that at least not completely
we can fake our way and to get the right
answer okay because we know what the
right answer is but we don't have a
single principled
fully rigorous theory
that describes the sun
simultaneously as a source of light and
a source of gravity now again in the
regime where it's the weak field limit
etc we can do fine but a full theory
um
isn't there for that so you
there's very few i mean to get this to
the spirit of your question there's
essentially no conditions that you bump
into in your everyday life where you
need quantum gravity but the world is
both quantum and gravitational
and i'm a believer that there's a way of
describing the world that is correct and
complete and that requires quantum
gravity
vicky ramsey says priority question
although it is a true statement that all
clocks tick at one second per second the
gps system and the nist relativity
experiments at boulder prove that the
duration of a clock second can be longer
or shorter as compared to that of a
comparison clock in examining the
engineering calibration process of gps
atomic clocks
in the frequency and energy proportional
when a clock engineer calibrates an
atomic clock does it require more energy
in order to cause the clock to tick
faster so i know there's a priority
question i'm going to address it without
answering it because i need to unask it
because i don't think that the words
quite hang together in the right way so
first you say
these experiments prove the duration of
a clock second can be longer or shorter
as compared to that of a comparison
clock
those the the comparison there is just
not an innocent clear thing because the
only time that the clocks move at
apparently different rates is when
they're in different positions
when they're not located at the same
place
so how do you compare them you need to
look at how they are reading things out
with light right with photons coming
from the clocks to your eyes and it
takes time
for the light to come to your eyes it
takes time for the light to go from one
clock to another so you're not actually
comparing them at the same time at the
same point in points in space time
you're inventing a procedure
for comparing them and the procedure
might be good or bad but there's a
reason why i don't like to say
that clocks change their rates in a
gravitational field because it relies on
all this extra baggage that i don't want
to have to assume
what i can say is that if you start two
clocks at the same position in space and
time and then move them around and then
bring them back they will not
necessarily have
measured the same elapsed duration
but that's a different kind of thing
that's more accurate than what you said
uh but it's not exactly what you're
trying to get at because what you're
trying to get at is like you say
frequency and energy proportional
frequency is one over time so therefore
does it require more energy
i have to once again say what do you
mean by energy
energy is not a lorenz invariant concept
energy depends on your frame of
reference just think about a photon
going by right
you can measure the energy of a photon
collect it in your little uh calorimeter
measure its energy but then the same
photon had you been moving toward it
would have a shorter frequency and
therefore more energy so there's no fact
of the matter about what the energy of
the photon is it depends on your
reference frame and that's true not only
for motions but also for locations in a
gravitational field
so that's why i don't like to talk this
language i like to talk a language of
what is happening in the reference frame
of the thing you're talking about
and in that reference frame the amount
of energy which is a well-defined
quantity now because i told you what
reference frame you're in to make a
clock tick is the same for every
physical clock made out of the same
stuff that's why that's how i like to
say it anyway your mileage may vary for
other people
john says can an electron be coerced to
revolve around a positron and if so
wouldn't this have the same spectrograph
as hydrogen uh so for the first part yes
it absolutely can and has been there's
something called positronium which is an
electron and a positron in a bound state
with each other
wouldn't this have the same spectrum as
hydrogen no because the mass of the
proton is very different than the mass
of a positron so
therefore you're going to get a
different spectrum one way of thinking
about this is you know think about the
sun going around the earth right if you
replace the sun with something the size
of the earth
the
period of the earth's year would be very
different
right the energy involved the binding
energy between an earth and an earth is
very different than the binding energy
between the sun and the earth likewise
the binding energy between a proton and
an electron is different than the
binding energy between an electron and a
positron so the spectrum is going to be
different
ken wolfe says you had a very
interesting discussion with brian kloss
on power and the temptation of
corruption
looking back on your own experience with
academia and other organizations have
you reached any conclusions on what
aspect of the organization's structure
or culture best works to discourage
corrupt behavior
um
so here's the bad news there's a very
very good question the bad news is i
think
the thing that the most important aspect
of making sure a culture
discourages corrupt behavior is having
non-corrupt people at the top of it
having the best people the most
influential important people in the
culture
be good people
that is not sadly a
fact about the organization that's a
fact about the people but if you have
bad people at the top
it's just hard for any amount of
organizational safeguarding to prevent
bad behavior throughout the whole
organization that is a i'm not a social
scientist i should say and that is my
very personal very non-evidence-driven
judgment so i might be wrong about that
but there you go
if you insist on you know
organizational aspects that might help
along the way i i kind of would point to
transparency you know a lot of
organizations certainly universities and
university departments
instantly try to protect themselves and
cover their asses right when something
bad happens it's like shut down
communication don't talk to anybody
we'll figure it out
this creates a culture of not discussing
bad behavior um because no one's
listening they can just cover it up etc
i think more transparency more openness
are very helpful but i don't know how to
really achieve that in any systematic
way so there you go
and last question tyler creighton says
if you were offered the opportunity to
host a popular science podcast along the
entertainer alongside the entertainer of
your choice do you think you'd take it
if so who would you choose as your
co-host
uh no i wouldn't take it good question
tyler and i know there are people out
there we have friends very good friends
who
do exactly this host popular science
podcasts or shows or give live talks
both a
science professor or scientist and an
entertainer of some sort i love the
format i think it's great you know it's
a wonderful way of
making things seem a bit less
intimidating a bit funnier and
especially crucially important
reeling in the scientists when they get
a little too
deep into the woods into the details
right you know some scientists even the
great ones that explaining and being
popularly understandable even the best
need
some reeling in sometimes so i get the
format it is not my format
you know as i said before uh
i'm in some sense not here for outreach
that's not why i'm doing this right now
outreach in the sense of
taking things we know and explaining
them
to people um
both because i'm interested in learning
myself
so like my goal here isn't to say things
i already know like if i know them it's
much less interesting to me in the
podcast format you know my books that
i'm writing the biggest picture biggest
ideas books
that's all pedagogy that's all outreach
that's all explaining things that we
know i vary explicitly in choosing the
topics of the book
eliminated the parts that were
speculative i don't talk about
bariogenesis much less um i don't even
talk about inflation for that matter
that much uh super string theory quantum
gravity none of that stuff it's about
the well-established stuff but that's
not the podcast thing for me for me the
joy of the podcast is that number one
i'm learning things as i'm saying i'm
talking to people who i want to learn
from okay that's crucially important for
me
um and i think that
having a co-host who was an entertainer
would not help me in doing that maybe
i'm wrong about that
but i think that i can ask the questions
that i want to know the answers to in a
more direct way
and the other is you know even more
lofty i'm not sure if it's achieved
but a harder goal that i still am going
to cling to
is not just me learning new things but
actually generating new ideas
doing real intellectual work i want the
podcast not just to be a recitation of
known true things
but an exploration of learning and
creating
new true things giving ideas to me and
to the guests and to the audience
um ways of thinking that weren't
previously there you know a true
intellectual contribution not just
explaining ideas but generating them and
again that's not
going to be uh abetted by having an
entertainer alongside um so again i
think that the
reasons to have an entertainer along
with the scientists as podcast hosts
make perfect sense
for certain goals those are not my goals
my goals are to really be out there
at the edge i'm going to be demanding of
you folks
uh i'm gonna stretch your brain
sometimes sometimes it'll be easy and
fun but sometimes it'll be a little bit
brain twisty
hopefully i mean the goal is every
single podcast makes you think in a new
way uh and i think you know there's only
an hour or so you know i know that some
people have three hour five hour
podcasts but i have people whose time i
respect who i don't want to
take that much time so between one and
two hours is about how long i'm going to
talk to somebody it's hard
to have a sufficiently efficient
conversation in that period of time that
you can really
gain new knowledge and get to the
frontier of ideas and and play around
with them and that's what i want to do
so
in my incredibly hubristic thought
process i think that i do that better by
myself than with an entertainer along my
side so that's my choice but again
let the ecosystem be diverse let
everyone do their own thing listen to
lots of different people hero worship
goes both ways i don't worship other
people no one should be worshipping me
thankfully that's not the world's
biggest problem right now so i don't
need to worry about it too much but
listen to lots of different people think
about it draw your own conclusions get
some thoughts that's why we're here on
the mindscape podcast thanks so much for
the support of patreon members for
asking the questions here i forgot to
mention this in the introduction i'm
supposed to say
the ama is funded by patreon supporters
thank you very much for all that support
i appreciate it immensely it keeps us
going
keeps the podcast uh humming along at i
think a pretty high level i'm very happy
with how the podcast is going as we near
our 200th official episode we'll have to
do something for that alright thanks
very much take care have a good month
bye
[Music]
you